Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello, hello YouTube and all fellow YouTubers
watching along.
Hello!
Hello, howdy.
Howdy, howdy, howdy.
Evening me yeah you if you have an account you're probably a
youtuber, right?
That would that would that would be like How do you like
what else would a person who watch you have an account
you're a youtuber if you if you There can't there can't be a
different different difference between differentiation
between a YouTuber who makes videos, a YouTuber who
comments, right?
If you go on YouTube, you are a YouTuber, no?
YouTube-y?
I am I-boo.
Yeah, technically they make you an account, make you force
you to make an account, exactly.
I am YouTube-y.
YouTuby versus YouTuber.
I am viewer.
You, YouTube.
Burr.
Viewer plus YouTube is viewer.
I mean, YouTuber.
Corrin!
Oh my gosh, you're turning 18 again.
Happy birthday!
Hello, me doing Ivo's like you!
I showed my brother your song.
I don't mention it somewhere.
And he loved it!
We might have gained another eyeball.
Let's go!
Yeah, Corrin, you should change to 19 again.
19 how many times?
ViewTuber, Rosa.
Oh, ViewTuber!
Wait, that's pretty good!
I'm a YouTuber and you are the ViewTuber, unless you're also
a YouTuber.
Sometimes I'm a YouTuber Wait, if YouTuber sounds so good
18 again, so like Is that like 36?
Why are we aiming so high?
Huh?
Why are we aiming so much?
Tube viewer on the tube.
As long as it's not the toilet.
Don't sit on the toilet for so long.
Sindhald!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
But I am 36.
36 years young.
37 37 here 37 years young
42 years young
34 years young rattles on 42 wait everybody wait 40 years 40
year olds unite There are so many...
Wait, there are so many people!
What are you?
What?
You guys know I'm forever 19, right?
Sorry.
Sorry if I have that zoomer humor.
You can't relate to the youngins over here.
You can't relate to this youngin right here.
I'm pointing at myself.
I mean, that was my birthday!
You know you're old when the ads say years young.
A nighttime groomer, Evelyn.
Thank you so much for a whole year.
Thank you.
Corian, welcome back.
Getting close to being 18 for the 18th time.
What would that be?
8 plus 8 is 16.
Carry the 136.
Just turned 34 yesterday.
Oh.
QG Lo!
Happy birthday!
My 32nd birthday is in six months and 12 days.
Wow, I didn't realize...
Sometimes I'll get, like, super chats from people being
like, I can drink now!
I just...
I...
I just turned 21!
And I'm like, wow!
I used to get...
I used to get super chats from people saying that they
graduated high school.
oh thank
you so much for the fun get it thank you 33 and a half but
in spirit i'm still 20.
in spirit i'm 19 i get it literal babies yeah i sent a super
chat when i graduated college that's much different than
graduating high school and you know it You don't look a day
over 50, Minto.
I sure hope not.
As a certified 19-year-old forever.
Call me mint word colon over here.
I can pay taxes now.
As a 26-month-old?
Wow.
We're starting them younger and younger, huh?
into the world and say you got this kid literally Pokemon
literally Pokemon your chat's more likely to retire than
graduate imagine having to scroll for 20 seconds to find
your birth year I know they don't go to the 1800s anymore
dang I graduated high school 13 years ago let's go Day job!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Back in my day.
So you are a Victorian child.
I've been saying this.
Sick Victorian child.
Was me.
Probably.
Who knows?
Anyways guys, welcome back to Pal world!
Yahoo!
I'm so excited to get back into my pals.
I want to go find the meow cat.
I want to go find...
Anything!
We can do anything.
I am retired.
Whoa!
Wait, really?
That means you did really well and you were able to retire.
That's so odd.
I thought of, I've thought like, you know, not anytime soon,
obviously, but like, say after VTubing, I have, it's like,
you know, what kind of other haunting am I supposed to do?
because quite a gap in my in my haunting resume so it's like
how feasibly how long could I do this until I'm like okay
well I can't do this anymore and then and then what do I
What do I do?
What am I supposed to do?
Forever, right?
I mean, I'd like to, I'd like to, as long as I can.
Maybe you haunt us in the retirement home.
You guys in the retirement home?
And I'm like, hey, Sunny, you ready for another stream of
PAL world?
She's thinking about life without us.
Well, you have life.
I'm thinking of afterlife.
I could be like, they just released the 15th Pokemon game.
The Gapmoe and my resume.
No!
Could you haunt my life?
I think I already am, no?
Retirement fund?
contribution like well i was thinking about it because like
because like you know my bob is always she's always just
like i know you're a ghost but like you gotta think about
you know the the afterlife the afterworld is a cruel cruel
world so what after this what you gonna do and i'm like you
know you promised to save for 10 000 years I was already
making plans to become immortal yes but after 10,000 years
then what then what then what there's also you viewer but I
like to think of myself as a Minto viewer of course you got
young and old viewers everyone loves Minto thank you get a
degree and something I like I don't want to blow all my
money.
I don't want to blow all my money.
Well, anyway, too real.
Too real, maybe.
Too real of thoughts.
After 10k years, what do you say we run it back?
After 10,000 years, guys, I'm going to rebrand.
I'm going to do it all over again.
New account, you'll never know who I am.
Please, don't search Blinto.
You'll never find the accounts.
Blinto Blantham.
Wait, it kind of is good.
Blantham.
The search is hard.
Blade Blinto
Yeah Can confirm middle age now And always a Minto fan Thank
you So in 10,000 years I'm going to need to rebuy all this
merch Yeah, pretty much Excited for new indie YouTuber Mant
Fintum I don't like the name Mant I don't want to be a Mant
I don't want I don't want to I don't know I veto manned
phantom phantom
phantom I'm so sleepy today I don't know why maybe I should
have another coffee
deciding if I want to get coffee right now before we
NAPSTREME.
I did eat.
Another.
Yeah, I had one for breakfast.
Now it's another.
Did you have any other aliases you considered?
Or did you always intend to just be your minty self?
Um, I did have.
Actually, I could probably tell you.
I can't wait for my new Oshida debut Freaky Plingus Um Well
from the beginning I always You know Like You know I'm dead
Kind of when I was imagining my image of ghostdom I think I
always had the minty image But I was like always thinking Oh
if I were to Leave the afterlife and reincarnate Into a new
being Um Wait hold on let me see if I can find The actual
concept What if I want you to say for one million years One
million Pal world Every day
Uh I will be the one to single hand single handedly keep the
servers open wait hold on oh I don't have it um hold on wait
let me check one more place uh so basically I had like a
sort of it was like a moai commander type idea which I still
want to do actually I had my mama an outfit based on the
character that I designed the character that I designed for
it but her name was will no her name was milko m-i-l-c-o
milko and then basically since she's commander type you
could say Roger Milko which is which was which is a play off
of Roger Wilko which if you
so i kind of had like a kind of had like a concept like that
um flipped around
so but you can when i ever get my military outfit which
which i have like a full outfit already done like rather
full sketch already done but my mama Ayami mama already has
it done it's just whenever I decide to go with it rather
than the other stuff but uh you could still say Roger Minto
it's not the same as Wilco but it works a little bit Roger
Roger Minto yeah Moe Commander sounds like an MSX Metal Gear
villain yeah well the idea was like you know Moe is dying
and so we fight for Moe and cute and justice
I had that and then another thing that I had kind of played
around with was if I stopped being ghost if I left the
afterworld and reincarnated was maybe if I could reincarnate
into a gargoyle because I was like gargoyles are kind of
cute Roger Wilco Milco Minto we will fight for Moe yeah
basically I took the same the idea is still Moe commander so
it works it works it works you don't think gargoyles are
cute
I like monster girls.
You've shared the gargoyle idea before, I think.
I have, I have, I have.
But from back in 2020, when I first appeared, or even when I
was, when I first made everything, it was always, always me,
always me.
Reporting for duty, Roger that, Major Milko, milking farm.
Now!
No!
Made everything!
Yum!
Not the Milko milking farm.
Actually, I think I came up with Milko after
I read the milking farm.
No.
It...
before no it was before mint in a military uniform it's very
cute would you ever think about reincarnating as a grocery
store worker as a grocery store is it because i keep playing
all these dang sim games no but us actually the outfit the
outfit i drew part of it my mama added to it but um she
really likes Roy Mustang from Full Metal Alchemist.
And so it's quite inspired by that uniform.
Yes, yes.
So you guys will see it.
One day, who knows.
My birthday today, Minky.
You don't sing anymore?
Oh, sorry.
Kiyosuke, happy birthday.
Well, I'll sing sometimes, but...
Please.
That didn't really seem like a please.
Choco Milko.
Yeah, like I thought the name could be pretty cute.
You're free to go coming to a checkout line near you.
Reincarnate as my wife, pretty please.
I thought we were already.
Orca, what the heck?
Stop cheating on me, by the way.
You act like I don't see what you're doing!
Just remember you can't shoot the IRL customers if they're
acting such.
I'm not even good at her stuff.
Cheaters and Minto's chab.
I know, right?
Oh, gosh.
What?
That's so crazy.
That's so...
What?
That's so crazy.
I saw a clip of someone with a Boston accent saying
gargoyle, but her accent was so thick it sounded like gag
oil.
Oh, I hear a gag oil.
Let's go!
Hello!
A ghost commander or gargoyle, please keep bringing you for
another hundred years.
We, we, okay, wait, so we brought it down.
Not 10,000.
Only 100, got it.
I'm changing the timeline.
I guess I'll have to get rid of that really cool thing.
I had it.
5,684.
Ears.
That's okay though.
That's okay.
Yeah.
Oh, shall we play a pal world?
Shall we play?
Just move it up in the timeline.
But I was saving for that.
What do you mean you are saving?
I'm the one saving.
Changing it again, now it is on Mintillion years.
How many numbers, how many numbers, zeros is that?
I'm going to take it back.
A lot.
Wait, I'm going to look it up.
Mintillion.
What is this?
It looks like it might be a typo.
Oh, wait.
I thought I messed it up.
Mint Lion.
What is this?
It's like some baby fashion brand.
No, wait.
Hold on.
Is it not a real number?
I thought it was!
Mandalorian?
Mint...
Tillion.
You're thinking of Quintillion.
No, I'm not.
I'm thinking of Mintillion.
The very real number of the many zeros.
Today, I want to see if we can beat the next boss.
I believe Nimi is playing as well right now.
We'll just go around.
I want to explore a lot.
I want to catch a lot.
I definitely want to get the Meowcat.
I want to...
I don't know.
I...
Anything.
She's working on the house.
Let's go.
Hello?
Oh.
What is this?
Power capacity.
Hello?
Whoa, she's all the way out.
Oh, she made a second base.
Oh, my God.
When did we get a second base?
When did we get to...
Oh, my God.
When did we get to second base?
Oh, la-la.
The Mintelorian and Dogu.
What is that?
Cool.
Well, we'll get out there, too.
One thing I do want to go look around for is...
Let's see.
I'm not gonna I'm not I want to I want to go out there
naturally I don't want to transfer over so we will go to
like here maybe
didn't didn't me make the second base
wait don't I have to wait no I have to give this to somebody
I got a bounty thing
I gotta give it to.
There's my baby!
There's the meow cat!
Wait.
Who do I have with me?
Okay, wait.
Everybody!
Be cool.
Everybody be cool.
It's what I wanted.
The meow cat!
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Go away.
Oops.
I didn't mean to use just a regular power sphere.
Mine!
Yes!
First mission accomplished.
So easy.
Another one?
Supply drop.
Supply drop initiated.
Yippee!
Best to enjoy getting to second base.
That sounds so close to me.
Whoa!
Do I have...
have yeah get on I'm super cold but don't we don't care what
is that oh it's a flock I'm like crazy cold oh my bad oh
shoot is he gonna get mad at me oh no ah never mind go get
them Just take them out.
There we go.
Ah!
Uh.
There you go.
Just kill them.
How is he not dead?
Take them out!
Whoa.
Everybody is freaking out over here.
My mercy ring.
Oh, that's right.
I have that.
I forgot.
Oh, I'm going to get a hedgehog.
That's what I'm going to do.
fun there's another meow cat over there the mercy ring yeah
that's right that's okay
let's get this guy oh uh wait what was over here the supply
drop supply drop no it might turn daytime first i mean we
have a little bit of time but cold wet but headed for second
and headed for second base
My little...
Meow Meow!
Wait, I don't want to use that one.
I didn't mean to.
I keep pressing all the wrong things.
My fingers are going all over the place.
Oh, another one.
Meow Meow, meow, meow.
We're gonna get all these and then we're gonna look at them
and choose the best one and add them to our...
My forever party.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
There we go.
No, please go away.
See, it's starting to get daytime.
No, no, no, no, no!
I need you!
Please!
Yes!
All right, we just need one more then.
I wish these guys had any loot here, you know?
Anything.
Tombat.
Do we want to grab this guy too?
Why not?
He's gonna disappear soon too.
Oh, shoot.
I'm trying to...
Might be fine.
Oh, I sold my other one, that's right.
Cool, then we got another one.
We got one, we got one.
What's this in the wall?
This area is so pretty!
Oh, it's an eggy.
They're guarding the stuff.
We'll let my guide take care of them.
Take them out.
Just kidding.
Yeah, take them out.
That was easy.
Oh, we have the schematic.
got oh i didn't actually want it but i took it but we got it
that's fine okay so what was i doing meow cat acquired and
then i wish we could get one more
we can't i can't head this way
It's a weather chest.
Beware anemi.
What does that mean?
What do we mean beware?
Where is she anyway?
Go!
Ah!
Did I scare you?
Yeah, you scared me.
Somebody ratted me out.
I was trying to sneak up on you.
I definitely wasn't checking my map just now and saw
yourself on top of me.
Thanks.
It's really good if you make yourself one.
I have one too.
I don't know if it's the same one.
I don't know.
It might be.
You're level 25.
What level are you?
Oh, you're not far behind me.
It's okay.
17.
I wanted to talk to you about the location that you chose
for the second base.
Wait, I didn't make it.
I thought you made it.
The second one?
No, no.
everything there was said made by mint made by mint phantom
wait what no i just logged on no but last time last time no
i logged in just to say hi to you and left maybe it was
matara it must be it was definitely matara then she's
trolling why is it really bad it's challenging i haven't
even challenging wait i haven't even been over to that side
of the map yet i was about to journey over there like an ex
like a epic journey this area is so pretty i know we should
i don't even think i have the ability to set up a second
base yet yeah i don't i don't think i could either i just
went over there and saw that all the pals were dying and it
was being caged by like level 30 fireburn creatures and
everything was built on a 45 degree slope so you can't build
anything oh oh boy
um yeah i was just about to head over there so i'm really
excited now for for what's awaiting things are more under
control now you handled it i i took it upon myself to make
some changes nice It was touch and go for a while.
We could just, like, you know, just, uh...
Take it upon ourselves to make another one, too.
That's true, that's true.
I've been building a house, though.
Yeah.
It looks so good.
But this area is so pretty.
I know.
We should have done it.
We should have made it here.
It's so flat.
It's flat.
and no level 30 pals we would be right next to those guys
though we'd have neighbors oh yeah that's true are they
gonna be there forever wait have you been over there uh yeah
i just i just killed them did you take their yeah i took
their pal is that swirdle no it's a flock there's a guy that
has a quest for a for a flock yeah what's the flock yeah
that's literally they're like give a flock
that's like the name of the quest i also just like i i
didn't walk to the base i teleported there so i have not
been anywhere in between no i was gonna like journey there
that's smart wait what are those things they're so cute
aren't they oh my gosh they're super cute Do you have to
like...
Is it one?
Yeah, it's one creature.
Here, I'll lower them.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
There you go.
Oh, do you have the thing that makes it so you don't kill
them by accident?
Yeah, the mercy ring.
I don't have that.
I'm just...
Tell me who to strike.
I'll get them down.
Wait, these are so cute.
Yeah, they're super cute.
I'm me only I'm my only I'm I don't know I think they're
like Cleone maybe like the jellyfish oh maybe I don't know
yeah this place would have been perfect look how flat it is
look how beautiful and so central to to uh that's true part
of the earth I mean it's it's kind of fun is it in that
volcano up there no no okay it's not i don't even know where
it is oh geez okay it looks pretty far out yeah i i just
teleported there okay you flock
yeah i'll have to teleport home and make some stuff too what
are you gonna do what are you doing today i don't know what
are you doing i'm journeying i'm adventuring i want to
adventure with you let's adventure i just want to level up
so i can unlock more furniture build the house that's that's
also valid that's where i'm at right now i gotta get more
stuff how was the gun the gun with the one bullet i used it
to great bag thank you of course logs on drops a gun yeah
plays organ trail yep yeah that was organ trail too yeah but
it's still like from the 90s oh it is it's not like a new
one no no but it um it was a uh it was really good i made
thousands of miles wait you don't sound convinced don't
listen to what anybody might be telling you have you played
like uh death road to canada that one's good oh no i've
heard of it though but i haven't played it that one's fun
it's a organ trail like oh organ trail like could possibly
be the first ever roguelike what is it oh this is the not
pikachu is it i mean besides rogue i guess besides rogue
yeah don't listen which one came first i don't know no you
stupid cat they're mine oh my gosh you're so persistent i
might have stolen all the resources from the base oh
yesterday you make my soul Oh, that's fine.
Yeah, make your... Oh, wait.
Did your sword take like a million years to make?
I think so, but I was building a house, so I didn't
really...
Oh, okay.
I was locked in.
Yeah, then you probably have the same sword.
The sword is really good.
The purple sword?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should try to fight something.
Yeah!
I want to fight the King Paka.
Have you fought him?
King Paka.
Uh...
I'm looking.
Wait.
You're high enough level.
Oh yeah, I did.
I did fight him.
You want to fight him?
He beat me up.
Yesterday.
Let's go get his butt.
Let's get his...
I'm going to let him touch.
I mean, die there!
Wow.
How do we get to him?
Where?
This way?
No.
Actually, he might be kind of far from here.
What about this?
Did you do this boss?
Which one?
It's between here and there.
Here and where?
There's all these guys up here.
Yeah, I see them.
Yeah.
oh it's pretty here too it is this one nice the bounty
target yeah did you complete your bounty quest uh i don't
know actually oh my gosh what is exploding over here this is
crazy oh no they've got a little hedgehog in there oh my
gosh Oh!
What's happening?
I think they're friendly firing.
I think so too.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Are you mercying them?
Are you catching them?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I died.
No, you didn't!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, how did that happen?
Grenades hurt.
everybody's down everybody's down it's okay I caught that
guy no I didn't oh I'm a liar I'm a liar oh that's not what
I meant to do well took him out oops dang it I was gonna
catch him when I arrived at the second base there was a man
working there there was already you should get this hedgehog
okay do you have one yeah it's cute it looks so sad
don't do it this is not the the boss no i don't think so i
don't know where we are neither i feel like i'm distracting
you i feel like you should lead the way no it's okay i feel
like i'm distracting you from your journey no we can we can
what you want to go get the the llama or whatever the king
packa we could we do have this wait can you hang the map I
don't know I'm trying to there's like markers can you see
the marker I put next to the king packa no no okay I
actually don't know how to get rid of it either wait oh I
see oh shoot oh delete delete
I don't see it.
But you can do guild markers.
You can?
How?
Oh, like that.
Guild marker.
Wait, where do you see it?
Um, it's in another tab.
When you place a marker.
Marker.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh, yeah, I see.
You want to go get that guy.
I haven't gotten him yet.
Did you find that guy?
Okay, let's go find him.
Yeah, let's go find him.
Wait, do you have this?
Uh...
Can we go to this?
Yes, I have that one.
Travel point first?
I don't have it yet.
Okay!
How do we get there?
Uh, it is.
Uh...
Can we go up here?
This one?
Is it this one?
Wait, am I going the wrong way?
This one, yes.
Can we use the...
The jumpy?
Spring?
Yeah, the jumpy.
Whoa!
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Oh,
why did it take me that way?
I didn't even...
Didn't even press anything on my keyboard.
Why did it do that?
Okay.
Part two.
Meantock!
I can't...
What's happened?
Okay, well, we're tied.
Okay,
now I'm climbing.
Yep.
I'm almost there!
What is that?
Purple chest.
Oh, nice.
Yep.
Regain, regain, regain.
Okay.
I'm almost there.
Hi!
I see you!
Yeah, I'm right here!
Who?
Come on up!
Yeah.
Yes.
Wait, this is a big tower.
Oh.
Is there a...
There's not a...
No, you just climb it.
There...
You might get, like, a cool cutscene, though.
Oh.
I haven't done, like, any of the main quest.
I've done just a little bit of it.
I thought that you would have done, like, so much of the
main quest, because you were playing a lot.
I didn't play that much, actually.
I guess...
the the next part of the main quest is over by the second
base i think oh it gives me a different area you jump this
thing right behind you it gives you a different area yeah
that's weird yeah so i don't i don't know where she went oh
is she gonna get her she gonna get the cutscene i i see that
we can see that tree from wait can you see the base the
second base that would be Wait, you can!
I see it!
Which one is it?
This way?
It's, uh...
Hold on.
I lost.
It's on that...
It's by the tree?
Straight ahead on that cliff.
That red roof.
You can see it.
The red roof.
Can you zoom?
Not really.
Need binoculars.
Yeah.
you it's like that that cliff that's sticking out uh-huh if
you go from the edge and then follow the edge back mm-hmm
it's like an orangey roof oh it's like flat a flat orangey
roof yeah I believe you I really don't know why I can't see
it wait maybe it's not showing up for you because you
haven't been there oh maybe Maybe it might, yeah.
Or maybe, actually, my view distance might be lower than
yours, too.
Oh, no.
Oops.
I'm going to crank the settings up.
Yeah, baby.
Crank it up.
The view distance.
When I get my second PC dual stream set up, that every epic,
every setting will be epic.
We'll do.
Should we go to the guy now?
Yeah, let's do it.
I'm going to do more stamina.
Um, where is he, though?
Oh, well, just find the fall of the guidance marker.
Yeah, I'm going to go for it.
Let's go!
It's a little scary.
No, we're going to make it.
We're so going to make it.
I made it.
Yeah!
Easy.
What have you been leveling?
Um, I've been leveling my stamina a lot.
That's, I've like, only leveled stamina yeah i like
sometimes do health and attack but stamina is so oh it's
like right here wait it's like right below us i think or oh
wait i'm looking at the guy where's the marker the marker
might not be exact it was pretty close though oh my gosh
lion king is it true there's no no uh fall damage when
you're riding on a pal that is true is it true i'm pretty
i'm going i'm going i'm following oh oh oh they're level 10
i think they're gonna get owned oh scoots
yeah yeah
didn't stand his chance.
I know, I know.
Okay.
Wow, he was just chilling here for no reason.
He was.
Now he's dead.
Okay, we could go to King Apaka from here.
Here, I'll do a...
I'm going to delete your marker, and I'm going to put the
marker on King Apaka.
Like, marker.
Wait, how do I do it?
Oh, how did I do that?
Just kidding.
Guild marker.
Yeah.
It's weird that you can't, like, put it actually on top of
the place you want to go.
Right.
Okay.
This away.
We could have caught Scoot, but I don't think I want to.
Scoot can be worth a lot.
on the on the black market you know yeah you're ready to
ride I'm ready go whoa thank goodness for no fall damage oh
wait I'm gonna have to climb or we can go around we can go
around yeah oh
she's going that way wait what'd you say There's a cave up
there.
Oh, should we do it?
I don't know.
Is it just one way at the black market inside?
Oh, I think they're all different, though.
If you have any.
Enter dungeon.
Oh, it's only in two.
Oh, it's dungeon.
It's only for another 40 minutes we can go in.
Okay.
Yes.
Do it.
Let's do it.
I have double jump, but I don't know if Nimmy would have it
with her wolf.
There's double jump?
Oh, yeah, my deer has it.
I wanted to get the alpaca.
Well, I do have an alpaca, but I keep forgetting to put the
saddle on it.
Oh, like to make it?
Yeah.
Actually, no, I already made it.
Oh.
I just forget to put it in my team.
That's fair, too.
Let's see.
What guy we got in here?
Oh, this is one of the ones that's, like, really deep like
if you fall in the cracks every cave i go in looks exactly
the same i think so i think they actually do wait there's no
friends in here oh no there's a cat
come here meow
i always feel so bad for them why smacking them because you
have to smack them i guess it's the same as pokemon yeah you
do brutal it's like when i'm doing it with my hands it feels
worse right then when you've got another another pal yeah
guys in here oh my god they all came at you you
got him you got him let's go they didn't stand a chance
either who's in here oh Whoa, it's this guy.
Oh, I like this one.
Oh, they're like babies.
Yeah, they are.
Yeah.
This guy's easy peasy.
It is.
Oh, I threw one.
Nice.
Good.
Do you want to get him?
If I fail.
No, you got him.
You got him.
I panicked and threw one.
Yeah!
Wait, is there any more?
Oh, that's it.
That's it.
There's the chest.
Oh, my inventory's full.
Oh, no.
My inventory's full.
Mine's full, too.
Um.
Mmm.
I could make hot.
Oh, wait.
My, I can have some bread in my...
You can take that one.
I'll take this one.
Yippee!
Oh, I leveled up again!
My gosh, I'm only one level away from getting stuck.
So, building material.
Yay!
Let's go!
I got curtains!
I unlocked curtains!
Curtains!
Wait, this is huge!
This is huge for our home.
It is!
We will never be sunny.
Just wait until you see the bathroom.
I unlocked the toilet, too.
What?
Wait, I'm so excited.
I didn't get to explore the house.
It's not that nice.
What are you talking about?
I bet it's so much.
But it will be one day, especially if I can get stone.
Stone?
You already have curtains.
We're like 50% of the way there.
I know, I know.
No.
Finally, you can take a bath with some privacy in the house.
Someone was asking for privacy?
My naplings were asking about it.
They did not lengthen.
I put a big window in there.
Wait.
Who's gonna look?
Oh, there he is.
I see no problem.
I'm guessing you want to capture this guy, right?
I'll try to.
Okay, I'll get him.
Yeah.
Oh.
No!
Wait, what's this?
I took one swing.
The server, the server.
Stack Overflow.
Hello?
Hi!
Oh, there he is.
He's back.
Okay, good.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'll start getting his, like, HP really low.
Oh, shoot.
He is pretty strong.
Oh!
Actually, we'll get my own.
wrong guy in here, too.
Oh, Meowbird!
Oh, everybody's dead.
That was cool.
He's dead.
Wait, did my cat?
Why didn't the cat of a go out?
Is that your cat?
Your level 23 cat?
Your level 23 cat.
Oh, he's gonna take so much fire damage.
Okay.
Be ready to throw.
You might want to throw now.
Oh.
Is this the wrong sphere?
Oops.
Oh, it's okay.
I think my cat died.
No!
Here, I'll call mine back.
What the?
I didn't call him.
That was weird.
Oh.
Yeah, get him, get
him!
Can you see the percentage?
Yeah.
No, I can't.
Oh.
But I saw you got him.
Yeah.
Thank you for your help.
This guy really beat me up yesterday.
Yeah.
We could take him.
Wait, I've never gotten one of these guys.
What level are you?
Asleep.
Oh, you're level six.
Level asleep.
What's this?
I was looking at that.
The green, glowy.
Statue?
Wait, is this the thing that enhances our...
Oh, it is.
enhances our base like you take it to the statue of the guy
and yeah oh willpower is the map why i don't know if you
know this the map is is randomly generated oh oh sorry were
you gonna catch him yeah but it's okay i killed him i think
i do have to go back to the base though for dropping stuff
off and resupplying I need more balls Okay, I'll go with you
Okay, wait, where's the closest one
Maybe the small settlement Oh, it is, okay Now the small
settlement, I think Yeah, I think so So we go, like, south
Ish Yeah, Oh, it, like, shows up on there.
That's on the map, I think.
Let's go.
Do you really get to keep the big Alpaca?
You do, yeah.
You can put him to work in the base, too, if you want.
He's that large?
Yeah, he's pretty big.
Nice.
Everybody's asleep.
We could steal from them probably.
Oh wait, can...
They noticed.
Wait, they did?
I have to run, Mick.
Go on without me!
Wait!
Oh wow, they're level 40.
I can't even help you!
I
can't...
Jimmy!
No, risk your life for a criminal like me!
Don't die!
I have to be here to revive you!
Uh oh.
Keep going!
Ride!
Ride your pal!
Oh, they're coming up!
They're coming up!
They're going!
Slowly!
I'm gonna fast travel back!
Okay!
Oh, travels back too!
They won't catch you!
Oh.
Where's all this meat come from?
Where did all this meat come from?
Who noticed?
How come these pals use it?
Thank goodness they didn't follow.
They didn't.
No, they're too stupid.
They'll never find you.
They never will.
Oh, you can ride the King Packer?
You can?
Wait, that's crazy.
I wonder what level the saddle is.
I wonder.
Wait.
Wait, I'm gonna go sell to the merchant.
What the heck is this guy?
We have, oh my gosh, Cognito.
Oh yeah, he's cool, isn't he?
Yeah, he's like the, what are they called?
Like a plague doctor?
Yeah, the plague doctor.
Oh, oh, it's morning.
Wait, where's our merchant?
Is he yours?
Well, he's not.
Do you live here?
He's supposed to, because you can buy and sell to him, but I
think someone took him out.
No!
Our merchant.
Let's see.
Fallen party increases the capture rate.
Ooh, earthquake resistant.
The King Pakistan is level 25.
Wait, was it 25 or 23?
But you can have it.
Wait, that means I can make it for you.
Yeah.
It's 23.
I'll make it.
Wait, you don't have to make it for me.
I got you.
Oh, thank you.
I can also make a gun.
Wait, I can make a clinic!
It looks just like you!
Yeah, I saw that in the...
Wait, I'm gonna make those things.
I'm gonna make them.
Yay.
Wait.
Is it under?
Where is it under?
I do need to make.
Oh, yoink.
Oh, ancient technology is an antique dresser?
Why am I on fire?
I want to get that.
Oh, wait, there's the Ring of Mercy.
Oh, you could just make it.
I see.
Whoa.
We have so much stuff.
I know.
I stole a lot of it.
That's okay.
Steal it.
Let's see.
I stole all three of their money.
of the what the cows oh yeah good job wait was that why all
the meat was left behind there was just lots of meat
everywhere i didn't kill them i don't know why i didn't kill
them
there's stuffy over here
oh they're so cute
I know, right?
They're super cute.
What is this thing?
No sand.
Aww.
I know they're so...
And when you hurt them, they, like, cry together.
It's so sad.
But, okay, I was building.
Building, building.
Building.
Where's the build, build?
The build, build.
No, the build where can I build a building things?
In the building thing.
Is it just B?
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
I forget that that's an option.
Isn't that?
Sorry.
Um, infrastructure.
I need nails.
Oh, I got some good stuff.
You got good stuff?
Some good furniture.
Oh, I need to give our bathroom a makeover.
Nails.
I believe it's gonna look so good.
When I logged on yesterday, everybody kept being like, oh,
to the second base.
Maybe the second base has all the stuff that you need.
They were setting you up!
Yeah, I gotta make the saddle.
This base is definitely a little more functional than the
second one.
It's getting there.
Here, look, this is where you can work.
Here, I'll just put it down and you can move it as you see
fit.
Whoa.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Look at that.
That looks just like my bag.
It does.
It's perfect.
It is.
All right.
Alright, let's see.
Uh, saddle.
Um, oh wait, that's over here, isn't it?
Sanitation level.
We don't think about that.
Yeah, not when we live outside.
No, okay.
Um, saddle for...
What do I need?
Oh, I need more ingots.
Okay.
What is that?
Oh, I see.
It costs...
Oh my god.
Oh, too heavy.
I'm too heavy.
Do you see how slow I'm going?
What?
Yes.
Because I picked up too many ingots.
I'm gonna make your saddle.
Can't you craft it from...
Or I guess...
Yeah, you can just drop them on the ground.
Oh, that's true.
And then you craft it from the inventory.
Anytime I need to, like, sword stuff, I always just throw it
right on the ground.
No, it wasn't in the chest.
it was in the thing you guys yeah in the thing yeah all
right select all right king paka i want to see how it looks
it'll probably be so funny yeah okay let's put some of these
um i wish i could put them
hmm i don't know what the sorting system is at all in here
everything is all over I don't think there is one everything
is everywhere mm-hmm oh
oh never mind oh okay then I'm gonna add that a giga-sphere
yeah that's what I'm making right now that saddles yours so
once it's done you Take it.
Thank you.
I love sometimes when you stand here and you craft, this guy
will come up from behind you.
Oh, it's scary.
They're working.
It's like all those scenes and movies and stuff where
somebody's teaching somebody else how to golf and they come
up from behind and put their hands over.
Let me show you.
Let me show you how to craft these games.
I feel so taught.
I'm just gonna, let's see, all of my schematics.
I'm just gonna, since I don't want to give up.
I guess I can give up the oil.
Yeah, we'll give these up.
We'll give these up.
I can just...
I always just throw everything on the ground and let the
battle sort it.
That's probably how these boxes got so...
Wait, that's crazy.
There's like the R sort that I use.
Oh yeah.
That's probably a better idea.
Yeah.
It's handy for sure.
Wait, I want that.
I think everything else I can still...
Whoa!
He's huge!
Oh my god, he's huge!
Why is it so large?
Oh, thank you!
This is amazing!
It's so effective!
Wait, oh gosh, this is too big again.
He's huge!
He's really big, yeah.
That's a large guy.
I gotta give him a name.
Trying to find anything in here is so tough.
I know okay one day I'll organize it yeah one day one day
one day in the in the future drink that um kingly slam whoa
mm-hmm that's pretty cool what is my I can do a kingly slam
watch the watch this cannonball wait where are you oh oh
like yours
cannonball it's like the biggest splash i've ever seen
wow this guy's awesome fluff bert that's so good
I'm never walking anywhere again.
I gotta use this iron up.
Let's see.
I feel like he's gonna destroy everything.
He could.
He very could.
I feel like he will.
Let's see.
I can make another sad.
No.
All the eggs are done too.
Oh, yeah, I've always wanted to have my own.
I'm taking that.
Wait, what is this?
The large container.
Oops.
Uh-oh.
I'm accidentally using my attacks.
Oh, don't worry about it.
I'm just trying to get off.
They can tank it.
Um, wait.
I don't need ammo anymore right now, I guess, huh?
What's that?
Charcoal.
I'm going inside the house.
Do you want the house tour?
Oh.
There's some pals clipping through the walls.
First floor looks pretty similar.
I recognize all this.
Whoa!
We have an incubation!
Oh my god!
Yeah, there's so many.
I don't know whose they are, so I didn't open any of them.
But I got a relaxesaur.
Wait, that's a good one!
Is he?
Oh, are they all Mataras?
It's okay.
That means you are definitely allowed to get them.
Paparai.
It's like gotcha.
It is, it is.
Are you getting any?
Yeah.
I don't want.
I'm not opening them.
I'm just scared.
Okay, I'll open all of them then.
You open them.
I've got Depresso.
Oh, no.
Hucretes.
Depresso.
Put this damp egg in there.
Oh wait, it's a little sad.
Oh no!
More depresso.
Relax-a-saurus.
So many relax-a-saurus.
Yeah.
Wait.
the bathroom oh it's in the other house oh wait the other
base on the other base whoa okay guys i think it's time to
journey over there the new house is way bigger yeah oh i'm
so excited enhance way fancier we can enhance with oh wait
didn't i get one though
oh we need three to do the next capture power got it yeah I
only have one does this work the the medical station I don't
know I don't know what you're supposed to do I'm not quite
sure right it's a sanitation level and it's like empty it's
empty yeah hmm maybe they'll they'll use it if you know I
need a med pal assigned to it oh a med pal I should have
known what a med pal is oh everybody knows oh it's it's
feeding time everybody's eating I'm gonna make some more pal
spheres make another 50 oh shit oh are you gonna be hungry
hey hello oh hi don't Yogi.
Hello.
My God, you guys are so, you're so juiced up.
Yeah, check out my sword.
We've been playing.
You guys are still using baby swords?
What, this is not a baby sword?
This is an epic sword.
Excuse me.
Epic sword.
Yeah, this is an epic sword.
Yeah, yeah, when you guys are still in the Stone Age, now
you guys haven't industrialized yet.
We're in like, we're in my pistols, my merit, like, was it
called by those shotguns um i've already made like five of
those uh-huh prove it show me a gun i have to make another
one actually i got a gun right here where am i yeah wait
check out my guns check out my guns you don't see them with
your eyes you're oh yeah your sylvan war your sylvan war
1800 uh bayonet yeah yeah it takes three It's a reliable
piece of machinery.
I wonder how long this shotgun will take to make, actually.
Wait, how long does it take to reload?
Wait, was this your only gun, Minch?
Yeah, what is that?
I'm making a shotgun.
It's okay.
I thought you had five guns.
Yeah, I gave them all away to other pals.
Oh, you will...
I'm creating an army.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's a little dog working here.
Hey, hey, where'd my pal go?
Yeah, five muskets.
Five muskets.
Yeah.
We're making a makeshift shotgun.
Oh my god.
That's dangerous.
This is literally how the revolution happens.
with a shotgun i don't think our poor fathers use this is
the industrial as someone has it has to be makeshift before
it is perfected that's true yeah we're starting this is the
industrial revolution baby oh my gosh i think i'm stealing
your xp points i just leveled up that means i get stone up
on yourself stone all right oh my god are we going back to
the stoning wait doki have you been to the second base yet
you want to join us we have a second base yeah let's show me
no this i haven't logged in since our stream oh i literally
came back from the bahamas today oh so sorry i made you edit
the server while you were on the page i was i was in the
bahamas i was like i can't access the server help help me
hey this is what happens take a break from your pina colada
and So I actually was actually an escape room because there
was like an escape room activity.
I got out of the escape room and I saw the SOS from Mimi and
I was like, oh shit.
Next time you can leave me on red.
Just enjoy your vacation.
It was like the last day.
It's alright.
You gotta pal it up.
What was the, what was the escape room theme?
It was like, I don't know.
It was on the cruise.
So it was, it was sort of pretty, you know, like that
makeshift shotgun, it was sort of like that.
Oh, no!
Wait, did you make it out?
Did you want to do it with children?
It was, oh yeah, there were, okay, so there was, I was
saying talking about it in Mimi's chat room, but like, there
were some kids in there because there was like four children
in there because it was like, you know, know summer vacation
is ending so the parents were like last week before you
gotta go back to school and then I felt so fucking stupid in
that skate room because it was like 90% math related oh no
terrible yeah and I was like stuck on this math problem
where it's like one so the number at top is like 13 and you
have to use eat and there's like one numbers one to 15 I can
use it one time and each box is like it's like 5 plus 3
minus 10 minus 5 equals 13 and then it breaks down even more
you gotta fill up all the numbers I was on that question for
like 20 minutes or some shit I gave up and then this like
teenager this 15 year old kid took over my question finished
it in like 5 minutes and was like I solved it and I was like
okay and then there was this other there's a seven-year-old
kid who was like stuck on a problem brought up his phone and
was like chat GPT how do I no in the escape room and then
like pops speakers so you can hear the phone trying to like
answer like the child oh no oh man it was it was It was the
escape room.
We did not escape, unfortunately.
That's crazy.
I didn't even know they had escape rooms on cruises.
On cruises, that's crazy.
Yeah, they did.
They did.
We had to pay $10.
You could pay?
Yeah, yeah.
Even though you already paid for the cruise.
I know.
Okay, I realized cruises love to suck money off of you.
Oh, yeah.
It was your first, isn't it?
It was my very first cruise.
realize you have to go to the places that says complimentary
I've never been on one either oh I haven't either it's it's
very fun just make sure they don't get you oh my god okay so
I was talking to like one of the staff because I like I
befriended some of the staff they on the cruise and they're
like I was like talking to them about like i don't know how
we got to this topic but oh yeah i was like what's the best
cruises and they were saying like there's this specific
cruise line that's really really good but it's all like 50
plus year olds because they're like you know they're they're
retired you know they have all this money to spend because
of that particular cruise line it's just all 50 plus year
old adults like grandpas and grandmas and i was like oh are
you bees grandpa so i was like oh so it's like a swingers
cruise right i'm cooked i mean
so i was like oh so like you guys encounter a lot of
swingers on those cruise you know because you know when you
you know that's sort of like the reputation and they're like
telling me um on there's actually a cruise that i had a
specific month called like on november 7th called the bliss
cruise where it's where people are literally naked what it's
not yes yes you're telling me i was like yes on november 7th
there's a specific cruise dedicated you remember the date
you really stuck with you i don't think you're gonna get a
ticket i was just like why because they're like yes and then
they're like they for all like it's literally this like the
like they were all just naked and i was like and what ended
up yeah so like i would they would be like yeah so like in
the auction on an art gallery auction they're all just gonna
be naked they're sitting there and i'm like ew sitting there
i think that has to be that's too specific to fill a whole
cruise ship of people who are interested in nude art
auctions how many people are into that they can fill a whole
cruise then that's all of them that must be all of them yeah
that was the all specifically i was just like what anyway
anyway so i learned a lot about cruises that day that's
crazy so don't don't sign up for any cruises on november
guys you might actually get on not specific november 7th
avoid any cruises on wait what was the date again so the
date again i gotta avoid her november 7th i said avoid all
cruises on us right yeah blis cruise avoid that yeah blis
i'm just making up the web page oh yeah blis cruise.com
everybody don't adults only oh my gosh it does actually say
that curiosity wait are you looking at the website clothing
optional cruises for adventurous couples that crave freedom,
connection, and unforgettable experiences at sea.
Is that allowed though?
Like what about when they like go to port and they're
flashing everybody from the cruise ship?
Like imagine you're just enjoying your vacation on the beach
and a cruise ship full of naked people.
Imagine how much you save though on laundry.
You just need two outfits there and back.
I was like, thank God, clothing is optional.
This one is the Wonderland Cruise.
That's November.
Oh, you got the day wrong, Doki.
We almost went on the wrong cruise.
Wait, wait, what do you mean go on the wrong way?
What do you mean?
It's November 9th.
Sorry, I'm two days off.
I'm sorry that you booked a ticket for the November 7th.
What am I going on then?
What did I get tickets for?
Oh, man.
Whatever it is, can't be worse than this.
That would be so true.
No, it was great, though.
Like, I literally, I forgot.
Okay, so I haven't been on a beach in a long time.
Whoa.
So I haven't put on, like, forgot how to put on sunscreen.
Oh, yeah.
I saw your tweets about getting super big.
I put all the sunscreen in the front Because I was just like
Yeah, the sun's gonna hit the front I forgot the sun can 360
you I forgot It's like your front is regular And then your
back is all red It's all red Because I forgot the sun can
360 I didn't realize it's all over I thought as long as it's
I see the sun and the sun sees me type deal, you know?
If I don't look at it, the sun can't hit me, you know?
So I fell asleep in the ocean.
You fell asleep!
That's the worst you could do!
I put my back against the sun on the little floaty floating
out in the ocean.
Oh my god.
Yeah, so it wasn't, also why do we have a shipping
container?
fuck is in i don't know who put this shipping container here
no one knows no one knows it disappeared randomly oh this
one shows off my arms oh check me out check me out you're
good thanks i feel good what what the pals do you have then
show us your pals i got them so many pals like you can't
even show give us a show actually that reminds me i want to
get i want to start taking out this pal this guy's gonna be
my new main he's my new main whoa your new main yeah he's so
cute which one do i want maybe the runner
fairly mean he's a little quiet so i got her up a little all
right sound team how is it now god you can't adjust people
individually can you no you can't you're also quiet for me
yeah you're quiet for me too nimi is fine though i think oh
am i quiet for you yeah you are for me a little bit all
right all right let's see yeah um so i'm also not at home oh
you're still in the bahamas no no okay so because i have a
sponsor today too so but and my manager was like don't do
the cruise you're not gonna get back in time and i was like
don't worry i'll be i'll be at home I didn't specify whose
home I'll be at so so I I was like I flew the closest
closest place I can do go stream and and I was just like
don't worry this setup will work I'm still trying to fix the
setup so you chose to play power world instead so no the no
the spot this is my test you know it's my stress test oh
okay okay it's monster yeah just volume and everything yeah
yeah it's pretty smart i guess yeah yeah trust the process
trust the process yeah well sorry sorry started blasting
yeah i know i cranked up my own individual obs it could just
be like my let's see my end somehow i feel like you're
getting quieter i know right i was thinking that too i like
just turned it up and then i was like oh nimmy's nimmy
thought i'm gonna be too loud i'm reminded yeah it's normal
all right am i am i still too quiet you're still pretty
quiet how about man am i just quiet on your end yeah okay
wait i got i got an idea the way he walks i got wait who's
your new pal isn't as llama no that's mine oh look at look
at how cute he is look how cute this cat is that's the whisk
i got one of those two yeah wait i gotta name them yeah
three of them well i already named mine i boo you can't you
can't take that that one's mine no mine's meow cat mine's
meow cat they're so cute meow cat wait pawbert is the name
of the enemy in zootopia 2 the antagonist wait who named a
pawbert that's fine that's neemie's pawbert yeah wait i just
realized he's more popular than the snake and this the snake
character in japan or some because he's like by famous
Japanese say you oh is he yeah I forgot move I remember it's
like they create so much merch for him in Japan I feel so
bad every time I release him he goes straight to work stop
working okay rest rest my little me okay job what is this
let me see how I can turn myself up for you guys I can save
the genetic data of these what oh yeah you can you can save
your genetic data and then like up if you have like a bunch
of them are you gonna clone them i don't know it's more like
oh what's it called um where you try to breed the perfect oh
yeah yeah yeah eugenics it's more eugenics than cloning meow
cat stop working meow cat you don't need to work you're a
luxury cat these are the worker pals It's like seeing a
feral cat and a house cat.
Like, yeah, it's like.
Let's see.
It's for transferring across servers is what my chat's
saying.
Oh, wait, is it a different thing?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you want to, I made an option so you can, if you want to
play it in a different server, oh.
I don't know why you would do that, but.
Yeah, who would do that?
Yeah.
Don't cheat on our server.
but like you could transfer a pal to a different server and
take your pal there oh yeah yeah i'm gonna go farm a level
99 team pack up bring him over yeah bring it over
i'm gonna go teleport i'm gonna go explore all right i'll
see you guys later yeah okay
Oh wait, Doki, you want to come to the other base?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to go to the other base.
Let me fix my stuff first.
Give me like five minutes.
Yeah.
Okay.
My challenge is trying to help me right now.
They're like, they're having a party right now.
Having a great time.
The input device.
What?
What was that?
They are having a party.
They actually are having a party.
They're having a party?
Oh, how's my volume now?
Is it better?
No.
Okay, all right.
Apparently it's not better.
Nope.
I'm gonna go.
I'm like body blocked by your llama.
He's a little bit humorous.
He's a little big.
I'm gonna gather these guys.
I haven't gotten one yet.
Oh yeah, these guys are cute.
The daydreams are so cute.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, he's alive, he's
alive!
Come back, come back!
What do I do?
Daydream!
Oh, you got him.
I'm making loud, how do I make myself loud?
Hello?
Oh.
Whoa.
Whoa, what's happening?
Why is everybody freaking out?
Oh, no!
Oh my god, they're attacking...
Oh my god, they're attacking that one lamb!
Why?
Over lamb.
Who did you aggro?
He tried to kill someone.
Somebody's stuck in the...
Oh!
Oh my god, they're obliterating this level one cat.
This poor cat.
Overkill.
What's happening?
They got aggroed like crazy.
I'm...
Show me the other base.
Okay, it's pretty far though.
Check the map.
All right, we can fast travel.
Oh my God.
No, we're not gonna fast travel to it.
We gotta explore.
We gotta explore?
Yeah.
Actually, I gotta pee real fast though.
I'll be right back.
Oh, okay.
Well, while you're peeing, I'm gonna do tech support.
My tech guys were like, we have a way.
They have a way.
But it's a lot of steps.
All right, sound team.
Tell me the wind.
Good luck.
Tell me the ways down, team.
Am I still hungry?
Oh, I'm starving.
Okay, I ran out of food.
I'm going to grab and steal some food.
I really want to go.
But.
They don't need this.
Sneakily upgrade the base.
Would I have a pouch?
Did I not make one?
Before anybody goes to see me.
Oh, shit.
I didn't make a pouch.
Oh, my God.
I'm not at the base.
Wait, where's the boot house?
I don't have stones.
I know I had, like, the shitty one.
Where's the shitty food pouch?
Do I not have it?
Oh, no.
Is that the shittiest they have?
Is that...
Yeah, I thought I had the small feet.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I can make it.
The small feet.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, I still hear her.
Oh, do I already have it?
Where is it?
Am I blind?
That's that, that's the bug that...
Just make it.
Just because I can't.
Someone else had last time.
Alright.
Hold on.
I'm gonna try to re-log it.
Maybe that's why she's quiet too.
Where is it?
Papa.
Alright.
Sound team.
What if I put my...
What if I up my thing up again?
Sound team.
How bad would it...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
can swap microphones but then we're gonna do this all over
again is it worth it I think it'd be worth it because the
microphone might I can't hear hello we'll see if that if
that fixes anything what happened oh but now I want to make
like a castle wait why why do I hear Nimi everywhere oh it's
a glitch so you might have to like you might have to log in
we could have new spawn steam wait where is she even no no i
don't hear her so like oh these ones i don't hear her so she
must be far if i hear she's you're really quiet and she's so
loud in my ear you have to log in okay i'll log out i'll log
out yeah yeah where did she oh she went to the second base i
could all i could hear was nibby
Maybe that's why she was so loud.
Maybe she was so loud because I could hear her everywhere.
Hello?
Hey.
Alright, take me to the new base.
I'm gonna teleport to the closest thing that I have though.
You probably don't have it.
The TP point.
Wait, then I'll just fucking travel to the base.
Okay, I'll see you there.
I'll see you there.
Okay, bye.
Bye.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna explore a little bit.
I want to explore a little bit.
I'm thinking near me, near me, oh-ee-oo.
I'm thinking, oh, weee-oo.
Let's open the ears.
All right, we got Meow Cat now.
Oh, I have a silver.
Wait, did I put...
I put away all my silver.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm gonna put a little thing.
They're both there.
We'll get there eventually.
Let's go westward, right?
That would be right.
Yeah.
Westward of.
Teleport back.
Wait, what do you mean teleport back?
Oh, oh no, it's fine.
I don't need it that much.
These things spawn like a dime a dozen.
Yeah.
It's not that important.
Ancient ritual site.
How long is this here for?
Oh, a long time.
But it's kind of tough.
It would be tough for me, I think.
Northwest.
Alright, everybody.
I'm excited to see this um whatever the heck sort of base
we've got going on actually maybe i should take out some of
these this thing though the
cursed base now why would matara do that hold on i'm going
around it but we're gonna go like this way i think it opens
up yeah there's a little pathway I want to level up my cat
too.
Oh wait, look at all this.
Look at all these guys.
There's a bunch of them.
Oh, you saw nothing?
You saw everything?
You saw nothing?
Maybe now we got them.
Yeah!
Oh, hey!
Get caught!
Who decided that POW ball should be a one-time use?
Am I right?
Cheeky bastard!
It's so funny that it just says that.
While we're on the way there, we'll level up and stuff.
How many green ones?
Okay.
Hi Minto!
It's my birthday today, so I want to say thank you for all
the laughs.
So far this year, I can't wait to see Skyline Serenade in
two weeks.
Undead Sea for happy birthday!
And see you in two weeks!
Happy birthday!
There's a mod that allows you to pick up Throne Spears.
Well, if missed.
But I'm not missing.
Oh, it's these Freakzoids.
We're always together.
Never apart.
Megasphere.
Oh, is this one needed lockpick?
Oh, no I do not.
Wait, I can use this on cat!
Yes!
Yes, meow cat!
All three?
What are you at?
Oh, 16!
We're getting there, we're getting there.
Oh, north, this way.
Right?
Yeah, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Let's enhance my stamina, baby.
Why won't you ride?
Chill it!
Chill it, you hate me!
Wait, I'm gonna die, for real.
Oh, there we go.
That was a close one.
Let's go this way.
I'm excited to see what sort of pals lie in the desert.
He's scared.
Wait, what is that thing?
Oh, barracuda.
Scutless.
Oh, you're scut- That guy looks like a baddie.
Wait, he's like even glowing red.
He's just absolutely evil.
Wait, you see this guy?
Yeah.
Oh, hi!
What are you doing?
Hey!
What are you doing to that guy?
I wasn't doing anything.
I was just passing by.
I'm going to the base.
Should we fight him?
He's level 36.
I think we could take him.
I think we can.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Okay, go for it.
I'll watch him here.
You're the carry.
You're literally the tank of our team.
I'll watch.
I'm deep.
I'm range.
I'm the range.
Someone who's gonna be able to catch him.
You have to use your Giga ball.
Yeah.
I have a hyper ball actually.
It sounds like a medical condition.
You're literally the tank of the squad.
Oh now, wait, where are you?
Why are you, you're literally the dog.
Like, what do you mean I'm right up here?
I'll just, oh, you're up there.
Oh, stupid.
I thought you turned into stuff.
I called her into cooler dad.
Yes, the cooler dad.
My bad.
Oh, they're blowing stuff up down there.
I don't want to bother them.
Oh my god.
Hit him.
No, I'm trying to get to the...
Wait, there's a cave right here.
My mom, why are you scared?
Why are you scared?
Yeah, maybe...
I'm so worried!
I didn't got you!
But he's Bowser!
I just run!
Oh!
I'm gonna be cooler dad died.
Cooler dad died already!
No he's not, he's not.
He's wanted to.
Don't worry, I got the high ground.
Oh my god.
The boss music happened.
Go, Chill!
I did 19 damage to him.
I'm doing one hit on his tail.
One damage.
Uh oh, uh oh!
Oh, oh!
You're so healthy.
I'm tanking.
You're tanking.
You got this.
Oh, no!
He's really strong.
Oh!
Boy, I think our tank's gonna die.
I'm trapped!
I think our tank might die.
He knows Hyper Beam.
Guys, he- Don't worry, I'm taking higher, higher ground.
I think, uh, I think I think this is it for us.
Sayonara!
Everybody!
Don't worry.
Easy.
No, Nimi!
Oh, shoot.
No!
Oh, he's on me.
He's looking at me.
I can't take him.
I'm trying to get away.
He's camping you.
No, let me get Nimi.
Let me get Nimi.
Five.
No, no, no, no.
No, no.
You have more.
Let's go!
We did it guys!
And we bravely ran away.
Oh my gosh.
We bravely ran away.
What?
Please don't
look at me!
I'm coming!
Tell me, help me!
It's okay, she's walking away.
He's walking away.
He hyperbeamed on me.
Why did you look at him?
I did it, I did it.
Why did you try to come back?
It was over.
He hyperbeamed on me.
He knows the range.
He turned around, we saw he turned around.
I did it, you saw nothing, you're a big fat liar.
We saw it, it's fine, our I saw you staring around.
What are these guys?
They're so...
Oh my gosh, they're so cute!
You're way...
Dark's cute.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should.
I didn't realize.
Oh, shit.
I should be dating my girlfriend.
I...
Oh, my God.
There's so many of them.
Wait, why are you frozen?
They freeze you.
Oh.
It's because I'm tanking instead of using a pal.
I just want them.
them just want them for the sake of it there was a big one
too there was a papa yeah there was his papa oh i want i
love the sweet they're so cute they might be my new favorite
oh you guys see the big boy the big papa boy big big papa
sweet wait i'm gonna capture this one too yeah oh you killed
him no i didn't oh you didn't oh he was like so close Yeah,
I have a mercy ring.
Oh, that's smart.
Yeah.
There's one more over there.
Yeah, there's two more.
Come here, sweet.
Gotta catch them all.
Steal coming in and taking my...
Hey!
You gotta be faster.
Wait, did we both get it?
I got it, yeah.
Are you duplicating it?
Oh, how?
That's funny.
Oh yeah, the big guys call Sweepa.
Sweepa?
Yeah, Sweepa.
Sweepa.
Where is he?
I don't see him.
I don't think he's here anymore.
I think he killed all his kids, so he left.
We didn't kill them.
We took them.
Wait, I wanna go to the new base.
I wanna go to the new base.
You see that pointy rock over there?
Yeah, yeah.
Have you ever visited the new base, Mint?
Huh?
Have you ever visited the new base?
No, I wanted to explore until there.
Well, I mean the house is great.
I heard other varying opinions.
Wait, on the house?
Oh, on the house!
Oh, I thought you meant the location.
Who did you hear about the varying opinions?
Let me see who said that.
Oh, I thought you meant the location.
Yeah, yeah.
The house I heard is great.
I don't know how we're gonna get up there.
Who's here?
How did you before?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
I think I never did.
I always just teleported.
Oh, you teleported.
Right.
It's right here.
I'll regain, regain.
Oh, there he is.
Turn around it.
There he is.
Where?
Oh, there he is.
Wow, he's huge!
Yeah.
Oh, he's got a mustache.
She's so cute.
Knock at you.
Sweepa.
He's really cute.
Make a null.
Wait, I'm making a null of sweet.
Wait, actually, why won't it, like, put it on the map for
me?
I think I touch it.
Do I?
I touch him.
I touch Sweepa.
Go get him.
Yeah, go get him.
No, he's afraid of me.
I know, is that sad?
Yeah.
Because you're trying to kill him in this kid.
I'm not trying to kill him.
Alright, come on.
all right
come on sweeper
oh shoot take him back take him back take him back
oh shoot come on come on there we go i need him i need him
yeah
to the base to the base i think you just up like from here i
can't ping i don't remember how to ping the whole way it's
like annoying yeah you have to climb i think we climb up we
climb up we got this yeah yeah we got this i believe how
many stamina levels you guys got um i'm at 240.
oh to be fair then you're at level 27 right
what I'm at, actually.
I think I have.
What do I have?
I have 167 of them.
We got this.
We're fine.
Yeah, we're practically here.
Oh, yeah, I have my grapple gun.
Oh, yeah.
Do I have one?
We only have to go all the way to the very top of that pride
rock.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the pride.
What's this thing?
Oh, I got one of those guys, too.
wait is it up there another sweep another sweep wait is it
up is it really up up I think it's up there no it's not on
the 45 degree angle why is my car is so stupid it has a
great views it has a great view you have to admit yeah I
have low I don't care about views.
How do we get up there?
We climb.
The trail eventually leads to the pride rock.
Oh, they're shooting.
They're shooting.
It's fine.
I'm biting the rock.
I'm trying to get off my pals.
Okay.
It's like...
It is like peak.
Oh, guys, did you hear the new update on peak?
It's like the final update, no?
Yeah.
Oh.
All right, I found a way.
You found a way?
Okay.
Yeah.
If there's a will, there's a way.
That's what I always say.
I don't even know where I'm going.
Oh, what's this?
Just go up.
We're actually making it.
Yeah.
Aw, mean.
Huge verdant egg?
Huge verdant sounds good to me.
That has to be good.
I don't even hear Doki.
The voices are getting quiet.
They are!
Wait, who's taking damage?
I don't know.
Did we lose Doki?
Doki!
Oh, she's over there.
I don't know where she...
Oh, she's like going a whole different way.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Go down there.
No, no.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe?
Wait, can I rest here?
Can I rest here?
Yeah.
There's a long, long, long way.
I'm just going right up.
What's wrong with going up?
Wait.
I might run out of stamina.
No, I'm gonna make it.
You're gonna make it.
We're going the rewarding way, that's what it is.
You're not making it.
Are you already up there, Doki?
Yeah, I'm already up here.
Oh my gosh.
Clearly I played Peekmore.
Wait, I can make it.
I can make it.
Wait, Neva, you made it.
I made it.
Not making it.
Yes, I am.
I don't know where it is even though.
Wait, is it that roof right there?
Oh, what the heck?
oh you cheated you cheated oh is it here wait is this it
yeah it's here whoa don't worry about the compressed house
though don't worry about don't worry about oh oh we found
them like that the base they could use a little a little
love but the house this is what matara khan does to people
oh my god the house looks great wow you had to use so many
many poles and stuff i want i'm ready to see the open air
bathroom wow yeah oh my god wait this is like this is like
gerald from the witcher it is yeah yeah yeah if it was like
a wooden bathtub it would fit the whole vibe why are you in
the toilet
I'm just helping It's like the poop stick You guys heard
about the poop stick Yeah Yeah I have Mint have you heard
about it The what?
The poop stick?
No What's that?
You should google it The poop stick?
I'm not gonna google that You googled the bliss cruise, but
not the true.
It's got standard.
Yeah, it got standard.
Wait, did that work?
I heard something.
What did you say?
Should we give you some privacy?
Yeah, yeah, sure you do.
Don't key, get out of here.
Wow, what a nice view.
Yeah, right?
It is.
Wow, wow, this place is huge.
There's room for everybody.
Yeah.
I know.
She's gonna flip the house.
Don't flip it.
But think about the property value.
The government's gonna wanna buy it.
No, this is, this is, we pass this down to our generations.
Our...
Yeah, and then our kids are gonna sell it.
No, they wouldn't.
They better not.
I built this thing with my own hands.
Why are our pets so...
Why are our pals so sad?
You're gonna put a data center next to it.
No!
Why are our pals so sad?
I don't know.
I think because two of them are sleeping on the floor.
Wait, but look how many empty beds there are.
They probably can't fit their...
It's probably the 40 degree angle.
It's the 40 degree angle.
They just slide right off.
I can't just leave on it.
That might actually be the case that they did lay there and
then slid off.
Oh, no.
That's so sad.
Oh, we have a mammal rest.
Whoa, wait.
We have...
We have one man.
Uchara left this man.
I mean, we can have more.
I can always have more.
Yeah.
Where did our merchant man go?
What's happening?
You're a merchant man?
Yeah, I captured a merchant guy.
And then I think Matara took him off the base, but you can
sell to him.
Oh my gosh, they're so cute.
Oh, if you capture him, I think she has it in her party
then.
Yeah.
She wants it in her team.
Fast as a fiddle.
I mean, she has the merchant in her party.
Wait, can you do that?
I never even thought about rolling up with a squad of six
dudes.
You could, you could.
I'm mad.
Who is that?
That's mine.
I'm mad.
The first man.
Oh, wow.
Look at him go.
He's like possessed.
What's wrong with him?
Why is he chopping down our trees?
Because don't get me.
He programmed into data center.
He's gotta be a man.
He's gotta let it out.
Start manning it up around here.
Alright.
I have to go to my sponsor, but you guys are still on after
an hour.
I'll be back.
Okay.
I think Snuffy might join in too.
But I'll see you guys later.
Bye bye.
you did a lovely job with the house thank you thank you now
that i have stone and curtains oh my gosh i'm a big fan of
the curtains i can do so much more actually i don't have
cloth oh no there should be i think i think the base there's
high quality cloth in this in this in this one it's too
fancy oh you need just regular cloth yeah um there's wool
you can make a cloth into oh yeah yeah yeah craft everything
why didn't she didn't make any like crafting things it was
it was pretty bare bones when i arrived okay she just set up
and left wow oh there's a thing down there in the bamboo i'm
gonna go grab that At that point.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go get it.
Yeah.
So I can teleport.
But I need my rider pals.
Oh, I forgot my pals are all dead.
Oh, I should put them in the box.
Versus Bowser.
Well, party increases attack and defense of sweep.
Oh, the little squeeze.
If you have them in your party, they will help the sweep.
Oh my gosh, we could just have like one, a big one, and then
a bunch of little ones.
This guy is fit as a fiddle.
They're so cute.
I love them.
Wait, we have so much.
We have so much wool, actually.
Yeah, we have a ton.
What else is around here?
You guys have hands?
Hands?
You have hands.
You need hands?
Hams.
Oh, hams.
No.
and oh everybody's awake wow that guy makes more beds yeah i
don't know i feel like there's enough for them they're just
kind of silly about it oh gosh they look i mean for us oh
for us they look really upset working they need they need
medicine but the medicine is so expensive and i i worry that
they're just again after i give them the medicine are they
like neo pets where they can be sad all the time and it
doesn't matter maybe i think so maybe then it's okay maybe
it's okay oh no what
else should i am like if they go hungry oh well they're not
hungry right i don't know i feel like maybe i need Another
farm for them.
I think we should have a faux tropical greenery set.
Yes, we should.
Absolutely.
Absolutely, I think so.
Oh, you want a ceiling lamp?
Yes, you have ceiling lamps?
I need to level up where I can get more stuff.
We're decorating.
I know it's fun that you get like the decorating stuff I
know decorating is is everything yeah boost oh this is gonna
be so fancy there's also fluffy pal beds hmm large yeah
those are good too I'm I'm too low level you're almost there
you're almost there am I
you can get eventually too hold on i have to correct
somebody in my chat do not say my pals are being overworked
underfed and denied access to recreation you need i need to
say this to the heavens matara khan's pals these are not my
pals this is not my responsibility i feel like i've been
here long enough that they honestly might be my
responsibility at this point oh no they never never what do
you mean oh Wait, you have been here quite a long time,
yeah.
I haven't.
You build a whole place.
Yeah.
Oh, you're going to get, like, the stone structure sets, the
stone gates.
Yeah, that's what I have.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's what you got.
I would like a piano.
Yeah, I have a piano, too.
Or I don't know if I can afford to build it, but.
How much is it?
Cross wooden boards.
and yeah those are all at the main base for sure yeah mm-hmm
oh my gosh we're so close lame organs I can get a real
handgun giga shield there's so many things okay I'm gonna go
get that waypoint okay let me grab my pals again I was
weighing on they should be good okay never mind they're not
good i saw they're still dead i see my my flame bird will
drop a flame organ dragon yeah there's a magic tree yeah we
have a magic tree maybe that's why she built it here i'm so
confused this location location is still questionable maybe
the clinic and assign a pal with medicine.
I'm here to adventure, guys.
I'm not here to take care of the pals.
Wow, it is a really nice view, though.
Wow.
Whoa, what's down there?
Yeah, that's the one that I want.
But, uh, that point.
And there's another one up there.
I wonder we could get to both.
Rank up!
Let's go.
Don't miss the part where that's her problem.
Jump?
Wait, what is going on down there, actually?
That looks like makeshift and funky looking.
What's happening down there?
Wait, let's go get my pals and check it out.
Mama rest?
More like, mama get to work.
Hmm.
Let's see.
This guy's resting.
Uh.
Got him.
Stone door?
Wow, that's fancy.
My pals!
Incapacitated.
It even makes a different sound.
The stone door.
The stone door?
Really?
Yeah, it sounds...
Sounds fancy.
Ooh.
sounds expensive made of money mm-hmm high level there oh
wow oh we're like a medieval castle now I know whoa maybe
maybe it has too many dungeon vibes no no I like it I feel
like I'm playing I feel like I'm playing oblivion now oh I
didn't even see this room this is so And there's storage in
here.
Hidden storage.
Very nice.
Yeah, it is like a dungeon, but everybody in my chat saying
what's wrong with dungeon?
That's true.
You could always just make it the basement.
Or like the, you know.
Oh, what if we have like barrels down here?
Like a wine cellar.
A wine cellar.
And bones.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
I unlocked gravestones, too.
Oh, nice.
You could put, like, oh, you could put them out.
Oh, what's this guy?
Maybe this should be the tavern down here.
Wait, that's a good idea.
Would that be kind of awesome?
Yeah.
Tavern.
Like a speakeasy.
Speakeasy!
Oh, there is stuff, though.
Oh, oops.
I just took your cloth on accident.
I'm sorry.
You can throw it on the floor.
Somebody won't pick it up.
You're right.
Put it away, probably.
Someone will grab it.
The pals are so useful.
I didn't even think about that.
All right, let's grab my pals, guys.
Wait.
Who are you?
Local restaurateur.
Huh?
We're traveling caravan passing through these parts.
It's faded that we've crossed paths.
Take a look at our goods if you're interested.
Whoa!
He's got omelets and stuff.
Wow.
Jam-filled bun.
Sacred mountain manner where nothing bad happens.
Yeah.
Wait, he's got a whole, like, bodyguard.
Should he, like, work?
here do you think oh they're a little tough but we might be
able to take them are they tough all right oops oh my bad i
didn't mean to do that is that the sound of a rifle no
what's what's going on out there nothing
oh he's on fire he's on fire he's taking damage he's taking
i mean i don't That'll make him easier.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Okay.
No, convinced.
I might have to hypersphere this man.
He dodged it.
Geekasphere?
Oh!
Oh, they know magic.
Oh, my gosh.
The police is here, too.
We got him?
I've been spotted by him.
Who?
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?
Did we lose him?
Don't fight the police, just let the pals do it.
No!
I think we lost him!
He's level 40?
Did he leave?
He might have laughed.
Dang it!
Our restaurateur!
Leave our pals alone!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, he's dead, he's dead.
They're using, they're using, like, Pokemon moves.
Keep saying I've been spotted, not sure.
Maybe he's in the house.
I know, I only have one star for this.
I can't believe this is only, only worth one star of
trouble.
Oh, wait, what do you mean?
Like up in the corner?
Oh, I'm two stars now.
Oh, is it because you're killing them?
Maybe I should start.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait, they...
Oh my gosh, they brought reinforcements.
Uh-oh.
Wait, they did?
They brought lightning dogs.
Lightning dogs!
Oh my god!
I think we're...
Oh, Demi!
Demi!
The synchronized.
We went out together.
Oh no.
I guess we'll respawn back here.
Oh,
that was kind of tough.
Are they still going to be here when we respawn?
I don't know.
I think that's a duck.
Am I going?
Yeah.
Until anyone can pick up.
I think that's pawbird.
That's yours.
I'm trying to not take your stuff.
Okay.
I think that's my stuff.
Take off.
Yeah.
Oh, that's your guy.
Oh yeah, those are my pals.
Uh oh, wait, are these eyes dead?
Or, uh oh.
Yeah, they're dead.
It's like a common occurrence around here.
Look, we got so much fiber and stuff from all the bloodshed.
From the chaos?
My inventory is like completely full too.
There we go.
Repair.
I'm just gonna drop it on the ground.
Oof, we lost a bunch.
Can I, like, pick them up or...
Are they dead, dead?
Oh, I think I put...
Those are wild pals, I think.
Oh, they're just...
Oh, no!
I think I put the ones that were here into my box.
So they'll respawn.
I don't know.
I think this guy is...
I think he was one of ours, no?
Which guy?
This mammal rests down here.
I don't know.
Was he?
No, no, ours is in the box.
Don't worry.
That's not ours.
Don't worry about him.
Okay, okay.
Oh, T-Bert, you're working hard, right?
Oh, yeah, he's extremely depressed.
Wait, wait, look.
Two of them are not even depressed, actually.
are in good condition i think they just started working
that's why no it's okay well i think mine are probably good
now yep all right i'll be right back okay do we have enough
farms for all of them i'm not sure oh yeah
oh does that him i think that's him stuck in the mountain
this game is so buggy it's awesome
all right let's go grab this waypoint down here okie dokie
uh where was it again oh down over there over there not you
All right.
There is.
I'll go this way.
Wee!
Okay.
Guys, we missed every...
Oh.
Uh...
This is fine, this is fine.
We're right there, we're right there.
Jump.
Don't miss, don't miss.
Okay.
Are we good?
We just gotta get to this bridge.
How's Powell World?
It's awesome!
I was a wanted criminal for a little bit.
I almost got to capture that guy.
I feel like I should have been able to messenger of love
Hey, there.
I'm the messenger of love and emotional expression.
I've come to deliver the refreshing joy of your heart's
heart desires Now let's try it's sit in chair together
that's I don't see that oh emotes Oh my gosh You received a
reward.
Oh, thank you.
Thanks so much.
Level 19, we got this.
This is easy.
And then we'll go get the waypoint.
Does she want us?
Maybe.
Ooh.
It feels like my game is lagging a little bit.
Whoa, Mammarist mate!
I got so many omelets from that guy.
I thought I would get my money back if I took him.
Calvary mushroom.
What do you think this is?
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh, there's human.
Disgusting.
Where's my meow cat?
I mean, I have a meow cat, but...
You know what I mean.
Oh.
He's chilling, he's probably fine.
Meowcat, go!
Look how cute, you are so cute!
You are so cute!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh wait, no.
Oh!
I love you, Meowcat!
I love you so much, I love you!
I don't wanna... I don't wanna exist without you!
Oh my god!
Oh, this guy's really just chilling.
Ah!
Yeah, blow him up, Meowcat.
Where'd you go?
Meowcat?
Come on, keep going.
Free hugs.
Free hugs from my cat.
Knox.
I don't know what this is.
Maybe I do know what this is?
Maybe I don't know what this is.
Oh, I have caught this before.
I'm a big old liar.
Oh, no, no, don't run, no, run.
Come on.
Come here.
Not nice.
Come
on.
Oh, shoot.
Come on.
Stop being difficult.
Knox is pretty cute.
I'll be honest.
Knox is pretty cute, I'll be honest.
Oh, this guy is...
Wait.
I can get the blast toys.
Not...
I can get the...
Bowser!
He's the dig toys!
He was presenting himself to me?
Meow cat!
Get his booty.
Meow cat's going for it.
Meow cat's tanking him.
Meow cat's almost dead.
Wait, no, meow cat, come back.
Oh, wait.
Oh, can I get out of this?
There we go.
He's a little tough for me to, uh...
He's a little tough for me to...
Oh, ah!
Nope!
There we go.
For me to get close to.
He is really cool.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god.
He's really tough.
Alright.
Chill it.
Do a little bit more.
We'll take him out.
Come on!
Oh, yeah!
Now we didn't have to go crazy style on him.
Nice.
Level 37.
Now I have my own.
Yippee!
Mm-mm.
He has great firing minerals.
rolls.
What's this?
Vital remedy.
Where was the book?
Oh, the book is here.
Ancient Technical Manual.
Hold on.
Let's put some stuff in my...
Like all of my food.
Oh, I was hungry!
Oh, no!
Wait, didn't I?
Oh, I didn't make the better slot yet.
The better food.
food bag or whatever but this can use it to obtain oh nice
and what's this do raises health by a slight amount when
consumed oh okay wait cannot be used in PvP I'm not in PvP
I'm not in PvP I'm not in PvP I'm swimming in omelets yeah
I'm Ah, nice.
Oh, that's not.
Sorry, my hand was...
Wait, where am I?
I gotta get back up here?
Alright.
You don't seem like a messenger of love with that thing.
It's a little intimidating.
Yeah, we're still in PvP, so I can't.
Oh, man, I didn't think we were in PvP.
It's a love gun.
Modern day cupid.
They've upgraded.
No need for...
for bow and arrow anymore.
Yay!
Oh, what are these?
Oh, I've seen you before.
Uh, herbal.
Doesn't even notice me.
He's so stupid.
And persistent.
Oh!
Hello?
Hey, hey, hey!
I wasn't... Wait, they all came after me.
They were like, how dare you?
How dare you go after my friend?
Oh, man, I got the wrong guy.
I got the wrong guy.
Oh, I got him.
Nice.
They're ganging up on me.
They were, they were.
It's fine.
I just met this guy for the first time.
I'm going to take his whole family.
You're mine.
Hey, family.
Friends and family.
Everybody comes along.
Don't you want to stay as a family?
You do the one, two, jump back, throw.
Works every time.
Works every time, baby.
The one, two.
Bug of my shoe.
Jump back, throw.
Yeah, you better be afraid.
I want a bird.
three four open the door five six throw the sphere seven
eight you're in the clear flight
is a game changer is it really
oh my unused stat points stamina stamina stamina nice nice
There was something around here, no?
Or am I crazy?
There's so many of these gerbil guys.
Herbal guys.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I was scared.
Why can you even fall in there?
How is that possible?
Now what's this here?
He looks eager to help with the logging.
Level 30.
Oh, it's a dungeon.
Sealed Ram of the Myriad Flames.
What is it though?
Oh, I could get a bird.
Whoa, he's kind of cool.
Aw.
Maybe I got him.
Hopefully.
Oh, come on.
Oh, I already have one of these guys.
I completely forgot.
When did I get you?
We'll get another.
Hello, Minto, and all the freaks in chat.
What's everyone's favorite pal?
Meow cat, meow cat, meow cat!
Meow cat!
Oh, meow cat, don't kill him.
Oh.
Hey.
Hey, stop being so stubborn.
Oh my gosh.
Why are you so stubborn?
Hello?
I don't even want you that bad.
What the heck?
Please.
Oh, thank you.
goodness why was that so difficult that was so difficult day
38 i think we skipped a couple i think the last one i got
was like day six i'm almost positive i don't have this guy
Whatever he is.
Depresso is so funny.
Gale Claw.
Oh.
Yeah.
A pal that can easily take flight even while grasping a
human.
It is, however, prone to letting go.
We're tired, which has led to the sudden demise of a couple
souls.
Rar!
What's a loop moon?
No, a loop moon.
Whoa.
Oh, he's kind of freaky.
Loop.
What are you in- what are you attacking?
I've never seen one of those before.
Loop mo- shoot.
Oh, God, you scared the heck out of me!
Oh, shoot.
should it be.
It's going after two at once.
No.
Yeah.
That was such a jump scare.
Which, did I just drop this then?
Because I'm going to discard this because I don't need an
old bow schematic.
It's like useless to me.
It's useless to me.
This is called efficiency.
So true.
They have ulcer and fracture.
I'm going to go take that back to the second base.
Wait, what's all this down here?
Oh, there's another loot moon.
Moon moon.
Cool.
Some more birds?
Yeah, let's get back to the base.
Actually, we could just teleport.
Drink the potion.
This one?
It literally cannot.
I... I... Please!
Don't back save me!
I know what I can and can't do, and I will do things when I
want to do them.
Oh, is this guy again?
He walks so funny.
I love it.
I'll get another.
It's almost daytime.
Eerie!
Wink-wink-wink-wink-wink!
Wrong backseeding, the biggest crime.
Yeah.
Let's see how Nimi's doing.
That makes a lot of sense.
Hello!
I was- I'm trying to fix this base so that the pals don't
don't become depressed again i was bringing over some
medicine for them really oh my gosh yeah but it's only for
like if they have ulcers or fractures but it's a lot of it
they're depressed might work it might work i think they need
they need the high quality medicine oh unfortunately wait
which i feel like is part of the the problem
doing so good um can i make that or do i need to have like a
special you can make it it requires horns which i don't know
how you get them horns wait i have some i'm pretty sure wait
can they get cured by the by the medicine by the clinic the
nimmy nightmare wellness center oh yes they can but i think
they assign a pal yeah you have to assign a pal for it i
wonder how do you see what kind of pal they are oh i see it
says it says it is are the bay are those band-aids lots of
horns huh is that the the medical pal oh yeah a hot tub
would be good i think probably a couple hot Wait, are you
a...
No, wait, that's really wood, right?
Oh, it's a potion.
A hot tub?
Yeah.
Yeah, it might be good, too.
Oh, yeah, we have some.
The moth is good.
Yeah, maybe if you could make a clinic, that might be good.
I will make...
Hmm.
Katav is so cute.
Look at him.
He's making biscuits in here.
Oh, he doesn't cure them with the statuses.
make a clinic.
Oh, I need wooden boards and nails.
Wait, do we have, like, a... Oh, here, here.
There's a work bench inside.
Yeah.
I'll make some nails, and then I'll make some... I'll get
some boards.
We'll put a clinic in here.
Do you have to, like, click allow transport my pals on
everything for them to move it?
I have no idea.
maybe oh my gosh there's so much ore here i'm trying to
acquire oh my inventory is crazy what to do hmm
we'll just drop some stuff on the ground
on the ground.
I drop it on the ground.
Okay, everybody's back to work.
Oh.
They're weakened.
They're depressed.
No, no, no!
Oh, no.
Cooking station would be good, too.
Oh, you need the flame organs, though.
Okay.
I think I have maybe as enough.
No!
I need two more wooden boards!
where's all the wood they're they're mining but where do
they use it all oh this house wait wait wait come downstairs
let me show you what i used it for okay okay
which way down here this way oh okay
wow wow i love what you've done with the place Whoa!
Wait, this looks awesome!
Thank you!
What do you have, Missy?
There's even storage back here.
Oh, nice rolling on the...
Thanks.
Yeah, get it, boo!
Yeah!
I'm just having a good time.
Wow.
It looks so good.
Thank you.
but that that's why there's no wood got it basically that
does pose a problem well they'll make more wood right where
do they put it so right i just got everybody back out in the
box i forgot that they were oh well they all died yeah now
they're back and they're still unhappy yeah this elgrove guy
He'll chop down trees.
Oh, okay, okay.
A mammoth rest.
What is he doing?
Oh, yeah, he's...
No, he's, uh...
He's currently working...
Yeah, he's planting.
Should I make one of them?
Do a tree chopping instead?
I'll just...
I'll just, uh, go back to the other base and grab some and
come back.
Okay.
I think that might be easier.
Oh, you have to make a tree farm.
Oh, a tree farm.
What is how?
That's the one thing.
I've been so preoccupied with running around, adventuring,
learning the ropes.
That I did not learn the ropes of the building of the...
of the um you know actual like work the base stuff yeah yeah
which it's fine it's fine probably uh what's this select
recipe oh this is just another one i want to make this i
need more flame organs We've got ingots.
I just need flame organs.
I know we have ingots in here.
Oh, we don't have ingots in here.
Would you like some unsolicited advice regarding POW
spheres?
No, but thank you.
Thank you for asking.
Yeah.
Look at this guy.
What the heck are you?
Never seen this guy before in my afterlife.
and this guy I've been looking at him too because why do we
have like a dang tea cup poodle work in the farms
um and also I can cook what is this stewed gale claw that
sounds awesome I'll be work in that.
I cook the pasta.
Wait, I kind of want spaghetti tonight.
Want to know something, Minto?
If you harvest chat, they will give you flame organ.
Chat!
Why?
I cook the pasta.
Acquire.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna put away my cloth outfit.
into somewhere.
Who are you?
Um, hello?
What are you doing?
Arson!
Oh, he's rekindling.
I thought he was setting the home on fire.
I was about to tell Nimmy.
Um, put this away.
Actually, I could just get rid of it, can I?
Oh, my bad.
we'll just discard it and I I misclicked that's so funny um
acquire because I want to make oh here let's make our large
feed okay let's make all of these oh work large feed bag
will be good you can sell it also I have to go I guess we
could have teleported to the town We had a very convenient
merchant That is now gone Somewhere Maybe Matara didn't
realize you could Buy and sell with him
Yeah, we had a guy We had a guy He would sell to you in your
In his sleep He was the best merchant around Uh oh Uh oh
Ooh.
We're probably fine.
Wait, which one is it here, or...
Which place is getting raided?
Oh, hello!
Hello!
Do you know which base is getting raided?
It's the original one.
Oh, okay, we're good.
Are we good?
Yeah.
You think the pals got it?
We've got it.
Yeah.
I'm here to help.
Thanks for the backup.
You got it.
I got my sword.
Do you want your gun back, by the way?
No, I have another gun.
But isn't the musket better?
Oh, I don't know, actually.
They sent negotiations.
Oh, don't, don't, don't accept, don't accept.
Should we kill them?
Um, eventually.
Yeah, we will.
Eventually.
who sent them I don't know honestly they're just like do-do
heads coming around I think that we should kill the
negotiator and send a message I agree
oh my god he lost his hair in the process it's like that's
if I were a serial killer that would be my my signature here
they come heard of their beer oh it's violent pals
Let me get me get my alpaca out.
Oh my god, wait, wait, I want some rare pals.
Are they rare?
They might be.
Don't kill them!
World 25!
Oh my gosh, they're killing them!
They're killing them!
They're throwing spheres!
No!
Throw the spheres!
Oh my gosh.
They're going in Sado mode.
Oh.
Oh, did you get one?
I got one.
Yeah!
Okay, no.
wave incoming okay okay oh they're pink oh my god wait
they're cute wait oh my gosh i keep missing no please i want
one oh my gosh oh my gosh i missed them all oh my gosh they
kill them so fast they do i'm like i'm oh it's a
relaxesaurus Ow!
Ow!
He killed me!
He got me down!
Now please!
Oh, your spheres!
Oh my god, they're so insane!
They give us no time at all!
I know!
I think maybe our pals are a little high level.
Oh, maybe a little...
Aw, but you...
Man, help!
Did you get any?
No, give me up!
I'm dead!
Oh,
you're so...
I'm not used to looking down.
people gamers don't look down gamers don't look down i got i
got one of the first ones oh nice nice nice no no he's i
don't even remember what it was he's yours he's yours
we got some oil did i have inventory oh my gosh these poor
guys in the crosshairs they leave their their stuff their
carnage they left a little bit yeah wait i think i got the
lizard too, maybe.
Oh, nice, nice.
There he goes.
That was exciting.
That was.
I wouldn't.
It's okay.
They'll come back.
Want the sexy lizard?
I mean, when you put her like that.
Here, here.
No, no, no.
I'm not going to take your sexy lizard.
You don't want my sexy lizard?
it's a good it's fine
what is this thing it's like a cave that leads to nowhere I
don't know Matara also did this she did so much I didn't
realize she got so advanced me neither me neither she did a
lot I'll send in I think I'm gonna log off soon I'm just
gonna go back to the base yeah of course but thanks for
playing yeah i'll see you later see you later good job
building thank you thank you bye-bye
she was busy yeah i feel like i don't know how much longer
matara played after she was on the server at the same time
as me but look at this guy just chilling here
um so i got another pouch And I oh here we are nice nice.
We got the food slot We got another food slot
I don't want my things expiring, you know Everybody full of
milk me too.
I'm full of milk too.
Everybody full of milk.
I want to make one of the armors one of the new armors that
I unlocked Like the pelt armor No
Metal armor.
I want to make the metal armor.
Actually, I think I can.
Wait, nobody's working on this.
We have nobody working.
I could have...
Do we use up all the ingots?
I could have sworn I've seen some around.
There was like... There was like...
so many!
I have... Yeah, I want the metal armor.
Where did all the ingots go?
Maybe at the...
Oh, maybe Nimby took them.
Oh, Nimby did make a sword, but it was before the stream.
I took, like, a hundred something.
I mean, they're definitely not in here.
Let's, um...
Hey, are you...
Hey, buddy.
I need you to make these.
I need you to work on these, please.
Please?
Please.
What are we heating up?
igniting what igniting what are we igniting what are we
you're just setting I set fire to the ground oh I'm climbing
our house any more pals in here yeah I got no eggs.
Is he running the heater for the eggs?
He might be.
Um, command console.
Oh my gosh.
I can't see anything.
Everybody is humongous.
Oh wait, it's a... Oh, we can also...
Oh, weapon assembly line.
A fire has broken out!
Wait.
Which...
A fire is broken out and it can't be the other one.
It cannot be the other one.
Wait, it cannot be the other one.
Hello?
It's going a little crazy over here.
Do you have a fire going?
I think maybe, yes.
It said the fire is in the base.
I think it'll be okay.
What happened?
Oh, that's just what happens every once in a while over
here.
here oh okay oh incapacitated yeah depressed oh no those
birds come and and light everything on fire oh no oh okay i
just wanted to make sure it wasn't your house thank you
thank you okay i'll be i'll be on my way then okay okay okay
all right see you see bye-bye wait actually do you have iron
there's a million.
A million iron?
Okay.
Maybe not a million.
I'm gonna I'm gonna take these.
Goink.
Okay, bye!
Mission accomplished.
No.
Okay, so good to know that our other base is built in an
area that gets constantly attacked.
Kindling, yes.
Okay.
wait so um what's the what's the thing that assigns is it
this thing oh set work no um fixed assignment here we go
here we go uh furnace you what are you doing anything what
are you
there we go yes yes more ingots more ingots they're very
important in oh we can make so much uh um average feed no we
got the large feed bag i got the small pouch i want to make
this i need more flame organs let's go um i'm pretty sure it
was like around
here that there were like those fox sparks or something
whatever they're called um And then we can...
Harvest.
I
think they're around here.
I like to harvest my own.
Murder spree.
Potato potato.
I think I'm...
trying to survive.
In this...
Hecken place.
Oh, we'll find one, I'm sure.
Oh, oh, oh.
I kind of want another cap ready.
Oh, usually, why is it that I can run into everything else?
But this time, oh, I miss.
Oh, I've really bad it.
Oh, oh.
You know, I think they've got it.
got it.
Am I back cold?
You miss every shot you don't take and maybe the shots you
do.
I don't remember what this quest was.
Oh my bad.
Where's the mammores that's Oh, there he is.
You think I can take on this guy now?
38.
We turn around.
Actually, let's try the fort.
Oh, that's right.
This guy's still angry.
Get bonked, Bozo.
Ouch!
Hey!
I'm trying to fast travel here, please.
Ladies, ladies.
Ladies,
ladies, ladies, what can I say?
The KFP of my love of me.
Alright, we're trying to find...
Mammal rest everywhere now.
Why is it...
Why are they suddenly everywhere?
If I were a little fuck spark, where would I choose to be?
Roaming the planes, looking right at you.
Oh.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
That's fine, though.
One flame organ.
Everything in this game shakes.
The UI.
The pals.
The people.
Everything in this game.
Is shaken.
Me?
You.
The boots.
My boots don't stop shaking, baby.
Oh, that was strange.
Yep.
Classic pal world things.
I love it.
Can you shake for us?
Oh.
Oh, I'm dizzy.
Oh, I think that was Nimi leaving.
Fare thee well, my brave Nimi nightmare.
Thank you for your valiant efforts in making our bases a
beautiful and bright one.
As bright as you make my afterlife.
Nice.
And they're asleep.
These suckers will know I hit them.
Give me your organs.
Yumi!
All right, we have enough for the new pelt that I want.
Let's go home.
I mean, do I evil?
It's not evil.
It's survival.
Yeah, maybe, can you spell survival as you are?
You can spell survival without evil.
Thanks for the raid.
Come back, la napplings.
I was just bidding farewell to Nemi.
Thank you, Steve, too.
Thank you for the gifted.
Thank you.
about to make myself a sick metal armor look at this wait oh
no i want this too the hip lantern this is why we uh this is
why we set out thank you thank you thank you thank you thank
you look at that thank you so thank you super liminal thank
you there you go thank you rest in glitch face thank you
thank you guys thank you thank you Thank you.
My Oshi is getting literate.
All right, let's now make...
Uh-oh.
Maybe we should go with the heat resistant though.
Or the cold resistant.
It's even...
Improved metal armor.
Rannabest, thank you.
when it's so generous.
I know, right?
I'm too lucky.
Oh, well, thank you.
Oh, there is more actually being made, though.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
So...
Those ones have even higher defense than the regular armor,
too.
Yeah!
I'm just wondering if it's like...
The cold one is the rarer one, so it's, like, better.
But...
Does it mean like I'm gonna be, you know, does it mean like,
oh my gosh, hello.
Yo, buddy, there's nothing in there.
That I will be, like, weaker to heat then?
Scooby-Gator, thank you.
You'll need both.
Okay, so eventually we'll want both.
Now let's take a nap.
Kisseraptor, thank you.
Doesn't lower your heat resistance, just doesn't raise it.
Got it.
Got it, got it, got it.
Good morning, Minto.
Then we will do this guy.
We'll get the ingots.
One.
And a two.
And a three.
Heat resistance is probably better right now.
You think so?
But this is just a better overall.
I'd have to go harvest more organs.
Just got home from work and I'm lucky I caught you before
the end of stream.
I got a fat ass burrito and a 12 pack to celebrate the
weekend.
Oh, happy Friday!
The blue stuff will be better.
Yeah, right?
We'll get this one then for now.
I mean, what's gonna...
Oh my gosh, this is gonna take forever.
What's gonna stop us from climbing the mountains, right?
I assume I can climb the mountain.
You get a little heat resistance from the cold armor as
well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did say that.
I said it was like level one.
Yeah, I might get a blue schematic for the heat later.
We'll aim for that.
I forgot where, but there is an accessory blueprint that
will give you increased carting capacity and level heat and
cold resistance.
Yeah, I've climbed the mountain before.
You keep working on that grisbolt and don't you stop.
I'm monitoring your work, buddy.
What is going on over here?
Oh, I have a...
Oh, it's hungry.
Me.
I'm hungry.
I'm going to go put away some of these seeds.
Wait.
I can't put away any seeds.
We have recovery meds.
Let's see what things I can take for...
Wait, why are...
Why aren't they drinking these?
I'll have one.
And another one.
Hmm.
Is there anything that can be used to raise my pals?
I don't...
Oh, the keys!
Let's take the keys again, right?
Heavyweight module.
Equipping it makes the sphere heavier.
Oh, that's right.
I'll take some silver keys.
Why not?
Oh, these are going to expire.
I'll just let them expire in there.
I like his tail bouncing up and down.
It's so cute.
Did I check this one too?
Oh.
Oh, lumber.
I think I put that one in there, actually.
Um.
We'll put this in there.
There we go.
This is yee.
Oh, I have egg.
Ingredient egg.
Anything I don't want.
Actually, egg is going to expire, so we'll just discard it.
This stamina remedy.
Isn't Meowcat so cute, I know.
I love Meowcat.
Let's go sell this, no?
Lee is punk.
I don't know what that is, but we'll...
Use to make clothing.
Interesting.
So we'll use that in the future.
We'll take our oil.
What's this?
Oh, ancient bark, yes.
Oh, we can't...
Should I just get rid of this?
Oh.
Because we can't drink it anyway.
So it just feels a little...
I'm going to use this on Meowcat because I love them.
Sell it?
Oh, I guess we could do that, huh?
Alright, we'll sell this.
We'll sell this.
Small pousel.
Ooh.
Stronger cake.
My cat is so strong.
Oh yeah, I need...
Wait, I do have...
Ta-da!
Nice.
Lumber?
I can link.
was there anything else oh yeah this we're making good job
buddy you're almost halfway there you're working on it real
well you're working on it real well
you drink that for you not the pals and improve i don't
think you guys can you can't read this item cannot be used
in a pvp
Please use your brains for two seconds.
Oh my god.
Who set the server to PvP?
Doki dead.
But since we're all in the same guild, I think we can't hurt
each other.
To drink the thing!
Yeah, nobody mentioned for you to drink the thing!
for all you know it could be my favorite drink and I'm
saving it for a rainy day a day when things didn't go so hot
and all I want is my favorite green drink
I still don't understand why I wouldn't be able to drink a
heal like a potion that makes me stronger I'm like in a pvp
server though i don't i don't quite understand why they why
the game doesn't allow it i guess to keep pvp fair maybe hmm
yeah it's kind of funny restriction
sorry to break it to you but it's carbonated definitely
can't have it already downing a midori and do in your steed
if you drink the thing you can complete the ritual well then
i'm definitely not drinking it oh my gosh guys i've been
having such crazy dreams lately i had a dream the other
night that i was cast as the main guy in rocky horror
picture show the one that tim curry played i don't remember
his name and i was cast as the as him And, but I was not
told until the day of the show.
I was, yeah, Dr. Frankfurter.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Frankenfurter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I was not told until the day of the show, and I told the
person.
I was like, I, I didn't practice these songs.
I don't know the lines.
I don't know anything.
And the director, she was like, no, girl, you got this.
just oh yeah yeah we're fine i was like hello yeah yeah we
we'll let somebody else take this oh my gosh i'm naked whoa
sick wait this looks awesome but i was like i don't know
anything and it was like this crazy massive like theater and
the director she was like no you got this you've got this
and i was like i i'm gonna mess up the lines i'm gonna mess
up the songs and and meatloaf song barely i've seen them
i've it's been like so many years since i've seen that movie
we're gonna go over here and we're gonna explore this area
now and oh gosh what else happened it was a couple nights
ago i had this dream so i was but i was stressing i was
stressing trying to learn everything in time
oh oh That's my favorite musical.
I hope you someday sing Sweet Transvestite while karaoke.
I've sung the time warp.
But...
It's been a minute since I've heard some of the other songs.
Oh, yeah, we've got this one easy.
Okay.
Next karaoke.
Tata, tata, tata, tata to me.
No, no, no, come here, Fudler.
Oh, he like...
He went in like slow motion, he was like,
I watched it recently only because of the time warp, but the
whole movie was amazing.
It's a classic, no?
It's one of those classic movies.
Wait, I've never seen this type of dungeon before?
Cool.
Two meows!
Yeah.
Yippee!
We're almost at level 30, you guys.
Oh, wait, where am I going?
Oh.
Whoa.
Whoa, everything's loading in.
Oh, there's syndicate.
get guy.
Whoa.
Wait, this place is huge.
Had an Oregon Trail dream last night.
I had an eyeball for a head.
Oh, there's two of them.
Got bit by a snake.
And you ordered the I think we should keep going guy to oh,
whoops.
To help.
Wait.
You had the whole cast.
Oh, Bye-bye.
What's the other way, though?
Hmm.
I'm going to check the other direction first.
Wait, was there another direction?
Am I crazy?
Yeah.
This one.
Ooh, we'll be swimming.
Whoa.
Wow.
This is so cool.
Oh, more guys.
I didn't just go in a loop, did I?
Speed.
Okay, I'm gonna aim it.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, that was
wrong.
I got my spheres back from doing that even.
Actually, I think this cold resistance is really good
because at night, chill it, is freezing to me.
So maybe now I won't be so cold.
Wow, this place is crazy.
It's a little spooky even.
I don't know why my game is lagging.
so much though.
Hopefully it's only on my end and it doesn't look so bad for
you
guys.
Spooky.
I feel like I'm playing Oblivion right now.
Who we got?
Oh.
I keep pressing the wrong button.
Oh little babies!
First try?
first try on all of them baby but before we leave let's go
back out yeah I keep like before dismounting I try to I try
to put him back in the ball wrong order of operations here
yeah
I'm 29 level 29 more stamina nice oh they came back
oh hey stop bullying them meow meow oh oh my god they held
their own They held their own.
Oh, my bad.
Okay.
Your pal?
Oh!
That guy!
Now where was the other direction?
Did I pass it already?
Really catching anything that moves.
That's how you level!
up though i've learned i've learned now oh my god
it just feels like bullying hey
oh please
let me catch you half listening to the stream we just got
off work any luck finding a waste ball.
Yes!
I got one!
Oh, wait.
Am I at the beginning?
Oh my gosh, I messed up.
I'm lost, you guys.
I'm lost.
Check out Meow Cat!
Oh, I did it again.
Oops, I did it.
Look at the baby!
Meow Cat!
I love you.
Oh!
Yeah, walking into my sword.
So, baby.
Like, actually, maybe one of my favorite designs ever.
So freaking cute.
But, um, I like the, what was it?
Sweer?
What was it called?
Palpadia.
Still so many of you haven't seen.
This one.
Sweet.
I was right.
Because it kind of looks like Obakinu.
It kind of looks like Obakinu, but with cat ears.
Actually, some Obakinu do have cat ears.
So cute.
Kind of does.
Yeah.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
No wonder I missed it.
You missed.
And so did I.
I'm just making enemies everywhere, huh?
So what could be over here?
Wow!
Oh, extra treasure?
Is this a trap?
Oh, that's it.
Oh, okay.
All that for what?
It is low level, you're right, you're right.
But how- I wouldn't have known.
How would I ever have learned?
I've never been in a cave like this one, so...
Oh.
Okay.
Let's get out of here, guys.
Let's get out of here.
This away.
Oh, I was so close.
Oh, there we go.
Alrighty.
Ooh!
let's go keep exploring actual places not dungeons all right
the bandits they're persistent if i saw myself riding in and
they looked as they look you know what i mean whims little
bozo people i would be terrified what would we get speed
remedy oh this answer a meat Wait, what does this one do
again?
Oh, work speed.
We love that.
A book that contains...
Oh, yeah, technology points.
We love that.
What can I make now?
Because I've leveled up a couple times now, huh?
Quality monitoring stand.
A font...
Oh, God!
We've
got an intermediate fishing rod.
This is huge!
Gigashield!
Wait!
Oh, my gosh.
I just...
I just made our hip lantern and now what is an anti-gravity
build helps players jump power extra weapon holster wait
that's huge what's the brothers of eternal pyre upgrades
upgrades all right human power generator
Gravity can't keep Minto down.
That's me.
Where the heck am I?
We were headed north?
Yeah, like around this area.
Well, it's a good thing I've got my cold clothes on.
Uh...
Sometimes...
Oh, there we go.
Chill it often bugs, I fear.
dark egg huh what does that mean meteorite descent wait
is this those those alien guys again am I gonna be in danger
yeah the ones I died to last time yeah
But I'm stronger, no?
I'm stronger now.
Where was it?
Oh.
I'm stronger now.
It's glorping time.
Oh, they're fighting them.
Oh, yeah.
I think we've got this.
No!
Hey!
Quit it!
Yeah.
Come on, please.
Please.
So I don't have to...
Yes!
The rematch!
The rematch is so real!
Revenge!
Yes!
I mean, they're only 15 now, but...
Oh, it feels so good!
It feels so good.
Sweet, sweet revengeance.
What are you gonna use the meteorite fragments for?
Well, I was gonna go sell some stuff, wasn't I?
Nice.
We take the bait.
Some cool special items?
Really?
What's this guy?
asleep.
Chill it!
I know you guys are wanting me to get flying stuff.
I will obviously eventually.
But...
Oh my gosh!
These guys!
Oh my god.
Whoa!
We got some new guys in here!
Wait, oh my gosh.
Chill it.
You can do it.
Just jump.
There we go.
Another relaxed...
Holy there.
High level.
Wow.
Not quite my
the mud.
But right now I kind of want to just go on things on foot
because I want to explore like up close and personal, you
know.
Alright, so let's go more north since
we can probably get these guys.
Oops, that's not what I meant to do.
I keep doing the wrong thing every time.
It's funny because I have the mercy ring.
I barely fight with my pals.
Initial flying is also very slow.
Is it now?
See, I wasn't even told that.
I do want to do the next gym.
But I'm nervous about my life.
levels right now you know last time i did it it was really
giddy giddy it was pretty scary so i'm like oh i'm not sure
if i could do it for myself again how's he ride on get mercy
yeah but i like doing it i like
i don't really like attacking with the pals because i feel
like i'm always clicking the wrong thing I wish it was like
there's basic attack and then there is.
Like just like attack but when I left like I left click and
he shoots himself across the map kind of situation.
Yeah I have trouble aiming well with the pals exactly.
I'm getting these so I never have to capture them ever
again.
I don't want them.
I don't want these.
I want these guys out of my afterlife.
You can set their moves.
Oh, really?
Can you now?
That is news to me.
Yeah, you're top level swordsman.
You don't need pals.
I feel like I'm pretty dang good.
For the gym, your level is good enough.
Maybe not without good support pals.
But with okay pals, your level is good enough.
You think so?
Still makes me nervous.
still makes me oh another guy what's the difference he's
shiny the
gold one is good no oh my
gosh once I once I capture this guy I'll be able to just
kill these guys I don't want them oh my gosh please
There's one in the water even trying to get me.
Oh my gosh, she's so stubborn.
Screw it.
Help me out!
Oh, the one guy you didn't need to kill!
Chill it!
The one guy!
No!
Yeah, swim away.
Swim away now.
Dang it.
Oh well.
Oh, there's a waypoint up there.
Let's grab it.
Oh, it's in here.
Oh, shiny fish.
Oh, if only I made my new...
My new...
What's the word?
I think I can make this.
Maybe it was my gun.
Fishing rod.
Fish and ride is the word.
Yes, it is.
Chillic got a little excited about being able to guard me.
I understand.
I'm not blaming my little guy.
Not blaming him one bit.
It's my fault, too, for asking me to do that.
for the additional help.
Okay, okay.
I like kind of going...
Oh, we made a little bit of a detour from where I was
initially wanting to go to.
What's this?
But that's okay.
What is this?
Whoa!
Special thing.
Nice.
So maybe...
Hmm.
A little fun base navigation.
Yes, yes.
Oh!
It's okay.
Finding a fast travel point is always a bonus in my opinion.
Even if we get a little off track.
Yeah, it's a good thing though.
that I got the cold gear because I'm pretty sure I'd be
freezing in here otherwise.
Yeah, get out of here.
Whoa, what is that?
Oh, incendiary grenade.
Bancy.
He felt your aura.
You're damn right.
Say my name.
Mint, mint, mint, mint.
Shiny.
Huge verdant egg.
This looks like a special or shiny than what I've usually
seen.
Am I crazy?
Highs in mint.
They really...
They really reward you for...
Okay.
for exploration.
It's awesome.
They're like, hey, that little tiny thing that you've been
needing for your base?
Right here.
Have I...
I almost feel like I've been over here, but clearly not.
I guess it's just a similar looking pathway.
You level up fast just by exploring.
Yeah, they are.
They...
Oh, look at that.
I'm already level 30.
Let's go.
Uh, whoops.
Uh...
More stamina...
Actually, I'm gonna do attack.
I'm gonna do attack.
I've been doing a lot of stamina.
But they're like, yeah.
Really great.
Oh, it's a Univolt, but...
Oh, Messenger of Love.
Cannot talk while riding.
Hello.
Hello?
You do not want to talk to me?
Oh.
I've come here to deliver the refreshing joy your heart
desires.
Now let's try hand over.
Are you robbing me?
Hand it over.
Let's try hand over all your belongings and everything that
you own.
Let's try that, uh, that emote.
trying to get to there.
I want to see what it is.
These guys, I haven't tried it yet.
Are you?
They're so cool looking, though.
One thing, okay, this is going to sound a little strange.
It's going to sound, like, pretty furry of me.
But the way that they animated the tails in this game, like,
look at that bobbin.
Look at that.
It's so satisfying to look at.
Like, it's...
Something about it just looks really good!
What is that?
The inventory is full for... Oh, the nails?
Oh, I think we're fine.
Okay, we're close.
We're close.
I think it's right around this corner.
Or in here.
Or up there.
Or... wool.
Is that it?
Terantris.
Whoa!
level was she 35 we'll hold off we'll come back i have her
now in my sights i have her in my sights
really good mount you think i could you can take her you
think so you can handle 35 guys i'm 30 but all my all my all
my guys all my pals are like 25 20 let's
get the whisper hill waypoint first and then we'll we'll
attempt let's get the waypoint first and then i will attempt
to get her because if i don't get if i don't If I lose, how
am I going to...
How will I get back here?
I don't know.
I don't have much faith in myself.
That's the main thing.
Oh, we're almost there.
We're literally...
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
I want her, though.
I want her.
Oh, it's...
Oh, level 20, grill!
Whoa!
Grill.
We can take this guy on, honestly.
Oh, oops.
I did it again.
Oops.
I'm going to use Meow Meow.
Meow cat.
Let's go.
Let's go Meow cat.
Let's go kill this guy.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh.
Oh, I did send it out!
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Take it.
Good job, Meowcat.
What did I get?
Shotgun shells.
Nice.
What's this?
Successful bounty token.
My inventory's full.
Vulcan Raven defeated.
We'll eat this.
And then I can add this.
There we go.
Nice.
Ooh.
actually i mean we can head back anyway because i got the
meteorite stuff i've got some eggs to incubate oh i have exp
scrolls oh i do have them oh thank you i don't even notice
seeing those um let's use them on meow cat
i don't even realize that i would bring meow cat to level
30.
i'm so proud of your meow cat nice
yeah i can make my new rod exactly
treasure the game is so generous honestly i think that's
what makes it very fun to play is how generous the game is
like a lot of drops don't feel like like if i'm like oh i
need an organ a fire organ i just go kill the one fox and
it's not like a rare drop or anything like it's so easy
It's so great!
Um, what do I need for my new...
Oh, wait.
Is it...
Oh, here.
A beginner?
I did unlock it, right?
Was I here?
Did I miss it?
Oregon's can be bought with money.
That, too, but I like harvesting.
Production line.
What even is the production line?
Wait a second.
I unlocked that technology.
What?
Mushroom cake?
I don't know.
Wait a second.
That's the breeding thing that they need.
Yeah.
Production assembly line.
This?
The conveyor thing.
Is it this over here?
Yeah.
carbon fiber the
one in the back the one that's carbon wait how am I supposed
to make that how am I supposed to make how am I supposed to
make oh I see I see but it's still just not my issue is it's
not showing up in my recipes all even though I unlocked it.
Fish.
Oh.
Why do I have to make it here?
I'm so confused.
Oh.
Uh.
I'm so confused why I have to make it here but okay.
Oh it's just faster.
Oh so this is like a this is a better workbench.
Is that what that is?
Oh okay.
Hmm, higher tier production.
Oh, some things are limited.
Oh, okay, okay.
It's the next level of the workbench.
This is so...
This is a choice.
Like, in my head, I would not think that this is the thing.
You know what I mean?
That would go after a workbench.
But sure.
I mean, it's cool.
Oh, wait.
Carbon fire.
I'll just throw that in there.
Once you get it, though.
Oh, let's set an egg.
Eggie, eggie, eggie.
Oh.
Wait.
Uh.
Wait, why are you on the ground?
Set the egg.
There we go.
Oh, shut the egg.
There you go.
35!
Ow!
Stop!
Stop the fire!
35 hours.
Incredible.
Maybe a little further away.
No.
You know what?
Not my problem.
Oh, wait, let's go sell.
Oh, I was going to say, why there's nothing showing up?
Because it's just this fish.
Broiled doom.
There we go.
Someone else can handle it.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, this is where the base is and everything.
This one might have been a...
Actually, that one might have been better, but that's okay.
investigator's fork this one was so close to the base I
didn't even see it
um we can someone else can have the the rod I will allow it
I will allow someone else to take the other rod and I think
we're good now I don't need this wool no duplicate not even
for the wolf okay
oh one thing i did want to do was fix my sword up it doesn't
oh oh five ingot never mind it's not that it's not that
broken never mind i lied um i'm gonna go to that town the
small settlement i'm gonna sell some stuff and then we'll go
back to the tarantula lady do the r button yeah but i don't
want to deposit everything and it's annoying to who was in
the other base because I think Nimi took all of it oh that's
fair let's see who will buy things from me village chief
will you buy things from me wow this guy looks like oh
wandering merchant you'll definitely buy oh wait no
oh hey flame organs I guess we could buy him from this guy
Okay, sell.
2,000.
Wow, that sells for a lot.
Wait, didn't I incub- Oh, I had another egg and I didn't
even see it.
We'll do the pelts, too.
Because it says their cells are good.
They sell for fine.
Um...
Everything just be munching in those game for real though my
goodness everything is just just munching and crunching all
around me
oh my gosh it's already been four hours you know i did say i
was when when nimi left i was like okay i'll go for like
another 30 minutes probably oopsie oh it's because my
inventory got expanded Medium pal, so...
Okay, let's go make these schematics.
This game is actually addicting.
Oh my gosh, and we can make it!
Work, work, work your little butts off!
Yes.
I'm starting to get hungry, though.
That's my one true...
My one true enemy is my hunger in terms of streaming,
usually.
I'm so cute.
I'm so cute, but I'm actually going to want this for the
defense.
I'm going to actually want this for the better defense.
Oh, man.
Um, la la la la.
Uh, oil.
I can throw this in there.
I've been keeping the dog coin for when we find that guy,
but you know what?
I don't really care.
Oh, the schematics.
Oh, shoot.
I don't want to make another thing.
I could go sell more of the vital remedies because nobody
else is drinking them because nobody can drink them.
Oh.
Just unlock the mirror.
Wait, what?
Don't forget about the egg.
I already put it in.
I've got honey too.
Oh, wait.
Sort.
There we go.
Perfect.
Sort.
I know.
Let's do this.
I know that if I go over to here and press A.
no nothing no but oh see the bones the bones went in the
bones went away all right we're good now there's a mirror
desk what that's crazy we'll we'll we'll do it next time
we'll do it next time because i don't know where a mirror is
just yet okay i'm no abyss we're gonna use meow cat because
my cat and we're gonna go try actually meow cat is yeah my
cat it was this way right Am I crazy?
Oh my gosh!
Relax just so it's locks!
Oh, the bohawks are so funny.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Level 50, I know.
We're a little, we're a little under level for those guys at
the moment.
I think it was around here.
wait eager to help with logging not right now not right now
dear they will aggro because they're red bars oh maybe they
like me we're flying
uh did i go the right way let's go through here Ouch.
And then around?
Over this way?
I believe?
It's like, is it in here?
Oh, hello.
Yeah, it's like in here.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, it's up.
Yep.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, my nails!
Okay, yeah, yeah, we found it.
We found it.
We'll get my Giga Spheres ready.
Oh, my God.
They're so cute.
Ah!
Oh, my gosh.
I'm trapped!
Abort, abort!
Am I going to be able to get my stuff back?
That was pretty rough.
Snatch and run.
My biggest concern is grabbing like a guy that will get me
out of there quickly.
Oh no!
Oh my gosh, I'm cold.
this could be the worst situation
wait this could actually be like the worst um possibility i
need to go up here
she does have a shotgun oh you know i did forget about it
because i haven't used it okay i didn't think i didn't know
if she would aggro on me um uh clearly she did uh
oh my god okay maybe they won't notice they're heading up
maybe they won't notice oh my god should take it all oh my
god we got so lucky
we got so lucky we got so lucky
Wow.
Is that a depressor?
Me after losing.
Yeah, me after losing.
Oh, depressor.
Your dang sphere.
Come on.
Come on, depressor.
Stop shooting as soon as you get out.
Hey.
Yeah, at least be depressed in the ball.
I don't know how many more of these I need.
Because I got a couple from the eggs.
Oh my gosh.
La cheeky bastard.
Yippee!
I need one more.
Depressos hot tub animation is great.
I've never seen.
well we have this whole area to explore next time we'll just
keep leveling up leveling up leveling up doing what we can
until i can get uh you know
the tarantula lady and stuff whoa those guys are cool
there's so much of the map look at this we haven't even
explored like of 20 like 20 like a quarter of it it's it's
insane the other fast travel point oh this one yeah we
probably can we'll do that we can get that that one before
we before we call it quit oh sorry mail kit
oh it is a good thing that i
Never mind.
We won't get that.
My cow.
My poor deer.
Holy cow.
Wow, guys.
The pal world was so much fun today.
I'm glad I got it.
I got to hang out with Nimmy, got to hang out with Doki.
That was good.
Oh, dear.
Truly.
That one was scary.
Nature's scary.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
We'll do more Power World next week.
I want to do some before I head off to Japan.
So we will do that.
We will do that.
And...
Yeah!
Thank you so much!
I'm gonna go eat dinner and I suggest you guys eat something
delicious too!
Otomito everybody!
Otomito, otomito, otomito, otomito!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night!
Break me!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Dorko, thank you!
Last bit was a bit stressful.
Bye-bye!